everyone's favorite journalist Taylor
Loren is furious because over on threads
she's being censored that's right for a
while now we knew that Mark Zuckerberg's
threads app which is supposed to rival
Twitter SLX was censorious I mean it's
run by Facebook Facebook is one of the
worst Tik tok's a bit worse but this
matters because we're now getting
reports that Walmart is joining The
Advertiser boycott and well we were
initially thinking of launching the
story with a comment from dick Durban
senator of Senator out of Illinois
Democrat saying that we should be
enlisting illegal immigrants
non-citizens into the army because of
the shortfall I thought well look we
can't have these conversations if the
platforms that allow Free Speech are
destroyed but this is while bad I think
there is some good in this many of these
people on the left these woke reporters
cannot deny now that Mark Zuckerberg is
worse for you than Twitter would have
been and if you want to be able to
criticize even Elon Musk you're going to
have to use x cuz Zuckerberg ain't going
to let you talk so we'll talk about all
of that we got a lot more stories of
course it's it's it's a bit of a wild
news day it's relatively slow but there
are a lot of stories just nothing
particularly massive so we'll talk about
a lot of it but head over to cast
brew.com and buy the best cup of coffee
you'll ever have we've got rise with
Roberto Jr our limited edition blend
appalache nights of course is
everybody's favorite we've got rise with
robberto JR stand your grounds we've got
light medium dark roast ground whole
coffee we've also got coffee pods for
those that want to just pop it in make a
cup of coffee very very easily support
our work by buying from casper.com and
you're also helping us launch our coffee
shops which are currently underway the
big thing we're working on right now is
I don't know what I'm allowed to say but
we're working on uh uh we want to be
able to get as many of these around the
country so that requires forming new
companies all of that paperwork is going
through contract negotiations working
with Chef Andrew gr if you want to
support that effort casper.com but also
don't forget to head over to timcast.net
that is correct thanks for having me Tim
um as you said I'm Kingsley Wilson I am
a trump campaign Alum and I currently do
digital media uh for the center for
renewing America in DC I'm also National
Committee woman for the DC young
Republicans so thanks for having me and
uh so Wilson's new it is new yes I
recently got married about a month ago
so you know I've been joking no longer
Cortez I guess I'm white now so I know
that privilege you all enjoy there you
go now now people are just going to go
ahead and yeah you lose your uh your
your your race card I got her sunscreen
as a wedding present wish I'm Hannah
Clair brimo I was really grateful to be
with the dcrs at their Christmas party
last weekend it was a fun time I am of
course a writer for cnr.com uh it's the
best also known as scanner news Tim's
laughing at me as what's a yr a young
Republican yes see I some other people
use letters too not just here at scanner
cnr.com um I can't have a good intro
because I'm now distracted but Ian's
here my intro is going to be even better
yeah it always is hi it's Ian Crossland
good to be here hi everyone good to see
Kingsley good to see you what's
happening search uh not much hey
Kingsley good to see you again too uh
let's just get into the show Tim
whenever you're ready here we go we got
a culture War start for all of you Alx
on Twitter says Taylor the Rens says
she's being shadowbanned on threads and
then a laughing crying Emoji now for
those of you that aren't familiar Taylor
Duren is a very prominent mainstream
media reporter she's worked for a bunch
of uh very large Publications very
critical of Elon Musk very left leaning
now she like many of other woke
reporters left Twitter complaining that
Elon Musk was going to make it riddled
with hate speech or whatever but now she
has these threads up on threads of all
places complaining that she is being
censored let me just tell you we're
going over uh you know our content prod
you know production and everything and
what we want to do and we want to do
sketches and jokes we're working on the
skateboarding show and uh I'm like you
know we can put whatever we want on X we
can go on X we can make any joke we want
no matter how vulgar or whatever and
Rumble too but Facebook will get banned
Tik Tok will get banned Instagram will
get banned that's obvious to anyone with
a brain so all of these woke journalists
that thought they were going to rush
over to threads and are now complaining
about it surprise surprise she posted I
posted the cover of yesterday's New York
Post to threads talking about how
hypothetical I'm sorry how how
hypocritical the New York Post is in
their criticism of meta when they
published the same for thinspo images
their bashing metaphor I don't know what
she's referring to what did threads do
locked me out of my Instagram account
until I deleted the thread and sent this
message to my thread's account saying
they're going to shadowban me absolutely
insane levels of censorship where we
can't even discuss the media's coverage
of meta on meta's own apps well on
Twitter you can talk about whatever you
want how are we supposed to critique
Media or cover the media when meta
essentially bans all discussions on of
certain stories and topics it's terrible
for free expression and I wish more
people in the media held meta to account
for their dangerously blunt moderation
tactics what I absolutely love about
this is that this is this tweet could
have been from six years ago on Twitter
from someone on the right and now it's
coming from a woke reporter who is on
Mark Zuckerberg's threads and she did
not have to leave Twitter like things
have gotten so much better so let me
just say this is I mean I guess it's
shot and Freud that's kind of funny
that's why Alex is posting the laughing
emoji to see Taylor the ren be like oh
no I'm being censored it's like well
that kind of proves our point right
others are probably just gloating in her
being censored but I think it's a good
sign and I think it shows you how
important it was that Elon MOS took the
actions that he did it proves him
right it kind of reminds me of the
reverse of when people who are liberal
and live in big cities move to small
towns and then want to change it like
she was somewhere that had free speech
left it and now it's like but why is
there no free speech this is crazy I
mean I don't think Zuckerberg promised
anyone anything other than to sell all
your data to China and that's my
personal opinion I think I I think uh
well I'll just go as conspiratorial as
possible I think threads is probably
uh intelligence us intelligence agencies
it's just feds I totally forgot it
existed but to your point this always
like cracks me up I guess like Alx
because I love when like this sort of
thing happens to leftist right because
it's the monster that they created
coming for them they were totally fine
with the revolution until they became
the target Taylor Ren I think the
Twitter files showed reported more
accounts than practically any other user
on the platform she was a champion for
the censorship cause and now it's it's
coming for her and I I think it's
hilarious to watch it's also this
phenomenon where people will go from
system to system to system and they'll
see the same problem in every system but
they'll go like this system's broken
some who's who's in charge of this
system fix it they go to the next one
this system's broken who's in charge of
this fix it but what they don't see is
the pattern yeah it would have been
interesting if she had been like as an
experiment I posted this thing to see
how meta would respond to it and they
have censored me and therefore meta
doesn't like whatever but instead it's
like I am the victim this system is not
helping me the way I think it should
it's not obeying my desires even though
it never agreed to give me these things
in the first place it's only worse
Instagram's way worse and the funny
thing is when conservatives and
Libertarians came out and said yeah like
yeah threads is way worse we all tried
it the leftist media organizations came
out and and accused all of us of being
conspiracy theorists and lying and
making these stories up and now they're
they're reaping what they've sown they
all jumped onto this I mean look X
Twitter whatever is this massive
and there's concerns about whether or
not there's going to be enough fuel for
it because all these advertisers are
pulling out fine but Mark Zuckerberg
pulls up on this dinging he's like
everybody up all everybody hop on board
and they're all like yeah and they all
jump onto this little dingy that Mark
Zuckerberg is driving around in and it
does work and now and this is what we
get so I don't know I guess people can
Revel in shoden frea or whatever but uh
going back to what I was saying I think
it's deep State I think uh we can say a
few things that are absolutely Fair one
it is not a conspiracy it's actually a
fact it is historical record us
intelligence agencies were in direct
communication with all of the big tech
companies running social media to
manipulate and control speech there this
was directly related to the hunter Biden
laptop interfering with elections that's
how extreme it was I was personally
targeted by the government and uh uh
leftist uh uh tactics with the um what
is it was it the EIC was it or was it
EIP election it was EIP right election
Integrity partnership or something where
they tried getting people banned and
taking things down and they did
successfully do this government
colluding with um researchers they call
them researchers this is how they can
launder government censorship we know
for a fact they're doing it okay then
Elon Musk says he's going to buy a and
he's and he's going to you know there's
talk of restoring all these accounts
bringing people back and uh oh deep
State's going to get exposed
intelligence agencies did get exposed at
the exact same time this is going down
Mark Zuckerberg announces threads simple
solution is that Zuckerberg said hey I
got a great opportunity to make a a
competitor right now to Twitter and all
these people who are mad elon's buying
it we can give them space a Canada
equivalent yeah and and that's and
that's a simple explanation and now I'll
give you the simple conspiratorial
explanation which I believe is extremely
likely to be true upon announcing this
the CIA the FBI uh Biden Administration
contacted Mark Zuckerberg because they
were already in direct communication and
said we definitely want to be able to
access threads in the the same way as
everything else and Zuck probably said
don't worry it'll function the same as
other platforms you will have access and
that's where we are now there's the the
Bolder more less likely conspir
conspiracy in that the Deep State
directly went to Zuckerberg and said you
got to do something about this you need
to make some kind of competitor can you
do it I would not be surprised to be
honest to find out that someone in
government went to Zuckerberg and
suggested it not that they demanded it
or mandated it but I wouldn't be
surprised if some emails got released
through a fo request something where it
shows someone in the Biden White House
said hey Mark are you able to make
something because you know this Twitter
stuff is bad and then Zuckerberg said
yes I think it's arrogance on
Zuckerberg's part though to think that
his uh technology and what he would
build would be able to compete with
Twitter SLX or whatever it was called at
the time I mean people are really
devoted to Twitter as a platform it was
revolutionary and what it was creating
and I think that original medium we've
seen other people I mean there's truth
social there are a couple other
competitors out there that just haven't
been able to achieve it and so to think
oh well because it's already connected
to your Instagram account therefore
somehow that will convert people I think
just shows how out of touch or how under
how much he underestimated uh X and
elon's ability to retain Bo supporters
like go+ remember that for like a second
but I forgot what it was and they had
Hangouts was that a thing yeah Hangouts
Hangouts were actually pretty big for a
while they were and it's yeah Google+
wasn't but Hangouts were because it was
the easiest way to do a a web- based
live chat with multiple people now it's
all Zoom or whatever but if Google made
Hangouts and and and kept pushing that
people wouldn't be doing Zoom meetings
they'd be doing Hangouts yeah cuz that
that's what a lot of people were doing
but they just had to get to that
pandemic earlier only only you know the
thing about Google is they just don't
understand how to be cool so what
happens is everyone's pissed at Facebook
so Google Plus announces you know we're
making a social platform and everybody
wanted it but they said no no no no no
limited users only send out a bunch of
invites tons of people signed up I
actually had what did I have I had like
500,000 followers on Google+ yeah weird
weird they totally Mis mismanaged
YouTube they should have made YouTube
The Social Network calling it Google
Plus and Google Hangout and Google this
and that and they tried doing that you
had YouTube they tried doing that and it
was killing YouTube so anyway what they
should have done at this point with
Google+ was as soon as the demand was at
maximum capacity and everybody wanted an
invite they should have said I'm sorry
everyone it's an exclusive platform only
and then 2 hours later said you know
what we're opening it up baby and then
they would have they would have won
instantly they did the same thing with
Google Glass they they launch something
everybody wants it and then they say nah
you can't have it and then eventually
some woke journalist goes well I didn't
want it anyway you're a glasshole and
then all of a sudden nobody wants to buy
Google Glass anymore it went from the
coolest thing everybody wanted to just
total garbage yeah I I had some faith
when Google bought YouTube that it would
be I mean they they were able to start
funding it with the partner program
which is pretty cool but like Larry and
Sergey are like uber nerds you know so
the company's kind of like uber nerdy
it's just the way it was built the E I
like them but they were nerdy there was
a period I think it was um let's see
what year would it have been maybe like
2013 or 14 I'm not sure no it was
probably way earlier than that Google
was trying to integrate YouTube and
Google+ they wanted they wanted Google
YouTube to turn into goog plus and when
they started integrating it
people started fleeing and complaining
like crazy and so then they backed off
like they had three stops you could
either go to Google Plus you could go to
your Google Hangout which was connected
to your Google phone number or was it to
your other Google account I had three of
them you know three different emails
attached to three different accounts and
I couldn't get them to consolidate it
was such a mess I can understand why
these platforms want to grow and become
more things they have to compete I mean
the same ways that Instagram added reals
the the short form video to directly
compete with t Tik Tok that makes sense
to me they're more similar but I don't
understand and maybe it's because and I
don't know if anyone in this room can
answer it I don't understand the point
of threads I've never opened it and I'm
not sure how it differentiates from the
YouTube like Community tab don't isn't
that what threads is like Twitter yeah
threads is like Twitter but then YouTube
has the community tab right like isn't
that where people can message if they're
like really into a creat or whatever
like no that's that's that's kind of
like a Twitter feed for your YouTube but
it's basically linked to your YouTube so
it's used to uh for the most part hey
guys heads up announcements see I feel
like it would make more sense to me to
have an integrated competitor to X on
YouTube because people are already alive
and well in the comment sections there
to make a competitor on Instagram seems
weird to me I just open threads and the
first thing I see I've got um let's see
Michaela Peterson and then uh Charlie
Kirk and there's two replies to Charlie
Kirk's post it's B three terrible I
don't know Charlie Charlie why are you
using threads you should make a threads
right now King I bet you could be the
most dominant person by the end of the
episode there we go oh okay I think
Michaela Michaela Peterson's responding
to a bunch of people criticizing her
dad it's exhilarating because all the
lefties went there though it's just like
a Cess poool of like it's an echo
chamber in many ways and I feel like the
fun Parts about Twitter about YouTube
are like fighting in the comments and
like seeing people dunk on other people
like that's why I love Twitter I think
that's why a lot of people love Twitter
so when you take that away you just lose
the user experience unless they start
infighting which could be interesting
who checked threads during the outbreak
of the Hamas Israel conflict cuz maybe
it was like alive and well then oh I
forgot to check my threads that's why
cuz that's when I think a lot of the
left was up in arms not that it wasn't
true on the right but that was a
particularly challenging times for like
the most Progressive angle of the party
versus the more moderate side uh they
were fighting a lot I wonder if threads
allowed any kind of discontent I don't
trust proprietary software in general
but I really don't trust public
companies when they do social networks
like X is private still at this I'm
pretty sure X is still private and Minds
is private you have Rumble well Rumble
just went public but that's like road to
co-op I want to I want I I we got
something interesting here I'm I'm going
to pull up this story real quick this is
from Mashable Walmart joins the X
Twitter ad boycott this one will sting
The Big Box store joins Apple Disney and
others is in ditching X over Elon musk's
comments uh this is uh by Matt bender
and he's he's wrong I think he's lying I
mean it's it's hard to say they like to
say Donald Trump lied and I always ask
well is he wrong or is he lying there's
a difference right I think Matt's lying
cuz I'm willing to bet in this there uh
yeah here it is here it is just in time
for the holiday shopping season Walmart
decided to stop advertising on El musk's
X joining a slew of other major
companies that have fled the social
media platform in recent weeks second
paragraph quote we aren't advertising on
X as we found other platforms to better
reach our customers a Walmart
spokesperson told Reuters which first
reported on the retail claim Chain's
decision to suspend an ad ad campaigns
on the website Walmart's decision to
stop advertising comes after mon said go
off yourself Etc Etc but uh the issue is
the greater quote from Walmart was
something let let me pull up Reuters cuz
I got Mashable here on purpose uh
Walmart says it's not advertising on
social platform act right but the actual
uh quote they say is has nothing to do
with any of this I'm pretty sure they
said we stopped advertising in October
not this is this is kind of crazy to see
a lot of newss are reporting this I
think there is a potential that Walmart
is trying to not be involved and and and
you know lower their amount of ad
but the the the the original story
reporting this Walmart said they slowed
down their ad spend back in October it
has nothing to do with what Elon said
now it's being reported by these
organizations that it's that it's you
know Walmart joining the ad boycott now
either way a lot of money is being lost
by X and one of the interesting things
actually I I just pulled up threads for
the previous segment and one of the
first things that is suggested to me I
don't follow Hank Green but it's Hank
Green he said numbers for the Curious in
the last 30 30 days Tik Tok views 37
million Tik Tock rev share
$3,600 RPM is 10 cents YouTube shorts
views $41 million YouTube shorts rev
$4,400 41 million views 41 million views
you said dollars oh no yeah sorry sorry
41 million views
$4,400 reals views uh doesn't report
minimum is 13 million his share was
$988 for a 77
RPM that's interesting in how uh you
make literally no money no money on
these platforms for all of these views
that's kind of crazy that on Tik Tok you
get 37 million views you get wow you're
getting
$3600 you have to be one of the most
famous people to make a living Hank
Green is one of like the biggest social
media influencers and he's only making
3600 a month off Tik Tok okay combine
them all and he's going to be making
what like 150k a year being the one of
the most famous personalities there's
almost no point in doing any of those
posts it's all just being whittel down
the crazy thing is when you look at X
and the ad boycott I'm wondering how
this will impact how much money people
are already getting because the rates
there are super low too I get like 200
million impressions on my on my profile
I get about 5,500 per month from the
from the ad share deal now it's probably
going to go to nothing because of what's
going on yeah as more people become
influencers too like every human pretty
much has a camera and can as their side
job make a video about what they do with
their main job at the very least that
the ad Revenue I don't think ad Revenue
models are the way to go I think it's
some super chats and direct
subscriptions plus then the The
Advertiser can't pull the rug on your
entire business model do you think that
this data will become public enough to
deter gen Z like this is what gen Z
wants to do with their lives most of
them want to be an influencer or they
talk about about wanting to be you know
a social media personality this is
regularly something they report if is
this sort of like when everyone wants to
be an actor and then at a certain point
I mean I'm sure you experience it too
people are like but are you actually
going to support yourself doing that
only a couple people make it big like at
what point do people realize this idea
that social media is the only way like
this influencer pathway is it going to
become less romantic for the youngest
generation hopefully soon cuz like if
you make internet videos but you do
nothing with your life they're not going
to be very interesting videos but if
you're a mechanic and you make in
Internet videos and you rope in the
mechanics into that it becomes very
interesting so they're synergistic you
don't want to like everyone in my
opinion should have the opportunity to
become an internet video star and and
you should highlight the cool things you
do in your life you could you could make
a YouTube channel where you personally
put things in boxes wrap those boxes and
then call it unboxing pres Channel and
you literally just film yourself slowly
unwrapping a box I'm I'm not I'm not
even alterate career ladies and
gentlemen no people love this stuff so
you've got viral videos of people
opening like Pokemon cards it doesn't
matter people just want to see what's
inside it's the weirdest thing so you
don't need to be interesting at all you
just need to make content and then
hypnotize people you know what I really
love I love the uh like the hydraulic
press Channel yeah me too I watch a lot
of that now there's like 12 of them then
there's the uh uh uh The Red Hot Nickel
ball where yeah there's like now there's
like 12 of them and I have I have a
really good idea idea that I wanted to
do but you know it's very dangerous I
want to electrocute things I'm like you
know how many volts and amps or whatever
until a teddy bear bursts in flame but
you know there's someone else to be like
yeah I do want to click on that video I
want to know how many volts it takes I
know and you know my idea was what you
do it live and then every viewer like
increases the voltage by a certain
number especially when water's involved
like watching electricity go through
water is fascinating see there you go
but that's the question and then you get
like 20,000 people watching and then
like the energy level is you know going
up that'd be fun right yeah I think
there's a lot of things it's not that
I'm against people making stuff
obviously and putting it on the internet
I I'm for it I just want that to be
clear it's just at a certain point does
it pay out the way people think it's
going to and is this a long-term
sustainable career because I think
that's why you need the influencer
ecosystem between all of the platforms
not one platform really generates enough
revenue for a medium-sized
person to sustain themselves is what it
sounds like to me and I don't know yeah
definitely not to sustain but like Ian
was saying earlier like it could be a
side hustle yeah I feel like a lot of
people have multiple jobs these days
anyway B an economy um so you know just
filming your job dayto day I think
people can put that kind of content out
there and it's pretty easy how many
people how many people have tried doing
the I'm going to drive an Uber and film
it and put the videos of conversations
on the internet I've heard that idea
8,000 times and I'm like yeah yeah yeah
get in
line let you do that they do record some
cars do record whatever's happening
right I'm pretty sure they do you just
got to tell people it's like hey like
when they get in your car and be like
hey do you mind if I film and then put
the thing on my YouTube channel and some
if someone says no like okay and then
you don't but Uber is a bad job anyway I
feel bad for Uber drivers you cannot
make a living doing that it destroys
your car no costs more to drive your car
yeah when I get a ride from the airport
to here and it's a 100 bucks I'm like
what is that like 60 40 of it goes to
the driver what is that's crazy and
that's all that's that's going to cover
gas and the wear on the car yeah and
they just spent 2 and 1 half hours
driving me like what in the heck yeah I
was reading like in New York that uh
Uber doesn't pay enough to cover the
cost of the wear and tear on the car and
gas but people don't realize wear and
tear so they're like all right yeah made
60 bucks and it's like by the end of the
month that money you're going to be
negative because your car is going to
break and then you have no job I wish we
still had taxis I missed taxis those
were great they still exist you know but
good luck yeah they they've been
protesting quite a bit mhm cuz they got
screwed over by New York but but anyway
man social media is a wild thing and I'm
kind of feeling like if we do move into
this AI automated future where all work
is is just being my nightmare yeah just
cars drive themselves I'm seeing more
videos pop up on Instagram of just you
know like we've automated this job and
that job and you've got all the
self-driving cars now the only job
you're going to have is competing with
each other to get eyeballs and then
humans are going to become more insane
than they already are M cuz already if
we're looking at you need 37 million
views to make three grand Imagine The
Psychotic behaviors people will adopt to
to try and make this work yeah they're
going to they're going to I don't know
develop U very serious personality
disorders but that's got to be bad for
it's got to
be do they develop them or do the people
who are prone to those personality
stores to drop do they want to be online
doing these things is it sort of like a
natural it's a m flame both I think this
is what wokeness comes from mhm people
are online and they're trying to find
ways to hit the algorithm and the
algorithms are leading Lemmings off a
cliff but what that makes me think is
like the market tends to adjust and
adopt for what is good and what makes
sense for society I think in general
Maybe not maybe it just leads towards
whatever is most addictive but if the
thing is bringing no value but adding
psychosis to the system I would imagine
that the market would weed it out why
what if we can't tell psychosis because
we're so used to it because we consume
so much of this content that we can't
tell the difference between what's
normal and what's not anymore that's a
good point we're there we're absolutely
there so if every Everybody believes
something because everyone's sharing it
I mean we can see the beginnings of this
with the Covington Catholic kids
everybody sees the video they assume
it's true they just said this kid got
that guy's face and then uhoh a two-hour
live stream was on coverage showing
actually was the other way around well I
was just looking up the uh what you said
like that Walmart had pulled the ads in
October and I found it but I had to dig
deep into to Google because even though
that was how they initially reported x
uh the Joe baronage I can't say his name
head of operations at X said that
Walmart started pulling its advertising
it hasn't advertised since October so
right the narrative that is being spun
at the top of Google is actually
different from the way it was originally
reported they decided what was coming
out they shifting reality and I think
that's been the best part of X honestly
like as a user we can fact check these
people in real time now journalists have
just been able to push their narratives
for decades and we haven't been able to
you know dig and actually find it for
ourselves a lot of people don't have the
time or the willingness to do that so
act slapping a community note on
something like this I think is super
beneficial yeah yeah there's a couple
ways to look at it it could be that
Walmart was the first to boycott and no
one reported it so if they're reporting
Trend Setters Walmart yeah I mean if
they're saying Walmart has just joined
no no no no because they stopped
advertising a long time ago or it's
completely unrelated but I'll tell you
what what what proves that it's all fake
I'm going to prove to you right now you
live in a fake world likely just being
perpetuated by the Deep State because
money is fake Fiat currencies here's a
story from India who is it Indian
Express there you go the Indian Express
Bastion of Journalism says X Twitter has
higher organic traffic but lower ad
Revenue than Facebook and Instagram Elon
Musk he posted this you can see
Twitter's s uh uh SE traffic 650.000
million paid traffic is 1.1 th000 almost
none paid traffic price
14.3k you can look at Instagram they
have 100,000 in paid traffic and
Facebook has 78,000 in paid traffic with
even less views so not only does Twitter
have way more traffic way less of it is
paid
traffic so this means with advertisers
pulling off of X or to give credit to
the leftists who are saying Walmart's
jumping Walmart saying we're doing
better on other platforms I don't buy it
I don't believe they are I've also done
advertising on these other platforms and
I believe that most of it is fake a bot
will watch your ad and then they'll say
well we assume it's real cuz how are
they supposed to know I knew these dudes
who were starting a company that's
that's their whole job uh the whole
company premise was to to you you they
would operate in between the company and
the social media platform so company
would say we want to do an ad then
social media company would say okay they
would go in the middle and track all of
the link clicks to see how many were
fake and how many were not and I think
they were telling me around half or more
is fake half so that means when you
spend 10 bucks you think you're getting
a certain amount of views you're getting
half that it's all fake so now we know
that Twitter is the best why aren't they
why isn't anybody spending money there
why spend money on Facebook when we all
know Facebook isn't giving you the same
return because Elon Musk bad Tim we
can't be anywhere near him him and that
orange guy yep I think the targeted ads
are enticing with Facebook you they
track people so well you can be like I'm
looking for 27-year-old males that wear
red hats that live near Philadelphia
that are awake between the hours of 4
and 9 pm. and like I don't know if
Twitter can can offer that kind of
targeted ad Revenue I mean even if half
of them are Bots that's still really
really good
targeting's but it actually means that
the price is twice as high because
you're getting half as many views it's
more than twice Oh you mean to to
advertise to targeted audiences is like
eight bucks for thousand views whereas
On Target is like $150 for a th000 views
but is that what your question was no
what I'm saying is like if I were to
spend whatever amount of money because I
think that's going to get me 1,000 views
but actually it's getting me 500 the
price per view is much higher than their
advertising but they're reporting to you
it's a th000 views and they just not
telling you that the other half are fake
let's jump to this story we got this
tweet from AI not kill everyone ISM
memes okay and they they are uh playing
a video from Sam Altman who says he
fears the impact that AI is going to
have on the election and it's not deep
fakes he makes a really great point he
says the main worry I have is not one
that gets airtime on the issue of deep
fakes he says we all you know talking
about deep fakes is fighting the last
war we we all have some degree of
immunity to this we know that when
there's a video or photo or audio we we
should check and make sure it could be
fake and then he's asked well then what
do you mean and he says the thing I'm
really worried about is customized
one-on-one persuasion ability a foreign
adversary that has trained their own AI
system that none of us even know about
like systems on the internet powered by
AI that are just like subtly influencing
you the interviewer says I fear
manipulation by AI EAS my concerns I I
just want to you know I bring this up
because guys we're 2024 is around the
corner we are uh we're going to be off
for the last week of this month so
there's only a couple weeks left we're
going to be doing shows and talking
about this stuff but 2024 is is is just
about here and this is already happening
100% already starting in probably 20
2015 and getting crazier actually I
think it's fair to say with the Advent
of social media this degree of
manipulation has existed and it's been
getting crazier and crazier and as of
right now I'm willing to bet you are
already being manipulated by AI now of
course I know the immediate reaction
from everybody is that's not what AI
means Tim you're talking about
algorithms and it's like okay dude no
we're speaking generally that computers
are automated to the point where they're
manipulating information in a variety of
ways to sell products or to get people
to win elections and I say AI because
it's probably already outside the
control of human beings so when you go
on Twitter when you go on Facebook
Instagram or whatever you don't realize
this but yeah they are probably you are
probably being influenced by this
machine that has no end goal no real
intention here's the scary thing a human
being has a goal I want this person to
be president for this reason an AI has I
want this person to stare at the screen
for 10s seconds longer mhm and that and
they will it will throw whatever in
front of your face to make that happen
now of course people are going to say
that's an algorithm sure fine if you're
talking about artificial general
intelligence then the real fear is the
AGI will make you serve it as a a
demigod master and you won't even
realize that you live for the machine
but you know in the general sense we are
all already being manipulated for the
2024 election it's happening now yeah I
think you're right I've stopped not
completely but I've kind of stopped
taking negative comments seriously even
remotely if I don't know who they're
from I even tell myself sometime it's
probably an AI and I know it's not
probably an AI but though it's possibly
an AI and I'm just not going to taint my
mind with that crap you're breaking out
of the Matrix yeah but the positive
comments I still take seriously what if
those are AI they might dead internet
Theory dude you know dead internet
Theory I know uh that what 80% of the
people on the internet are are fake are
fake and you go and you're talking to a
computer dude you're standing in front
of you I got 1.8 million followers
almost 1.9 million followers and so when
I tweet what people think is that
there's a million two million people all
standing there like with their phones up
recording when in reality maybe it's a
100,000 who knows they do they have
these apps where you can like check how
many files are organic and whenever I do
it it's like oh they're all real or
whatever I don't buy it I think the
whole thing is fake I tweet something
out I get a bunch of generic random
anime or whatever and I'm just like I
wonder if AI that Sam alman's talking
about is like all it's trying to do is
confuse you so whenever you make a video
you make a video about I walked in the
sky was beautiful today you get a
comment of no it was really nasty out or
you say I really like this candidate for
president well that candidate's really
nasty don't you see and then I assume
the AI wants you to continue to interact
with it that's what its ultimate goal is
because it needs your input to have data
continue to make decisions about what to
do next I mean I have a very rudimentary
understanding of AI but that that's what
seems like it needs it needs human
interaction to continue to basically use
us to figure out what you like to do and
to to potentially behavioral model or
whatever and so I what I find
interesting is that we have been letting
ourselves be susceptible to wanting to
interact with the AI for a long time I
mean this is what we talk about with
young teenagers who are essentially
addicted to social media because they
see all their value in the number of
likes the number of engagements how long
their snap streak is all of these
metrics to say
open the open your phone right now you
have a notification you have a click you
want to respond you don't want to be the
one who doesn't respond to the Snapchat
store you have to have something up
actually if you're Instagram page you
know if you interact with it enough it
gives you more it's more likely to show
yourself like it's always driving you
back to using it all the time which is
also what the AI wants you to do the a
AI wants to continue to learn what
you're doing so it needs you to
constantly come back to it right and he
mentioned specifically you know foreign
adversaries I think it's important for
us to realize that this isn't just China
like it's our own government to what
extent our you know agencies like the
FBI and the NSA using AI to influence
American citizens when they go to vote
at the polls in 2024 I mean I think that
needs to be a real concern because you
look at an agency like the FBI who has a
long history of entrapping Americans and
pushing them and incentivizing them to
do certain things I think you know we
can't put it past these guys to be using
this to reach their own ends and private
companies for sure like reading about
the business plot this Smedley Butler
plot 1933 these Bankers tried to get
Smedley Butler to overthrow the
government install a fascist
dictatorship is smle Butler was like the
top General on in the United States they
really wanted to overthrow March 500,000
dudes on Washington this is like a real
plot why did they want to do it cuz
Federal FDR took us off the gold the
gold standard and they were like he's
going to destroy the economy we have to
take him out of office and put a put a
general in and and become fascists like
musolini it was so crazy that they like
and they're just totally willing like
the Federal Reserve in formation on the
The Jackal Island these guys have like
the the the private sector when we talk
about foreign agents that the private
sector are foreign agents corporations
are foreign agents to our government
they're not part of our government they
might exist on in the United States but
they are foreign agents so they might
also very well be the ones trying to
manipulate us well I'm not sure well I
mean we know for a fact it is the
government manipulating us along with
the massive corporations so you know
welcome welcome to the nightmare welcome
to hell baby it's going to be look we
talked about this last week I post a
deep of Nancy Peli a year and a half ago
and it looked hilariously bad and
disgusting you post a deep fake of Nancy
py now and it's hilarious and realistic
where are we going to be with AI voice
uh deep faking it's going to be perfect
so we're we're we're going into 2024
deep fakes are bad but the the real
issue is that there's probably already
right now with GPT being public there
are probably millions of AI chatbot
accounts on social media that are
programmed just to respond in certain
ways but slightly unique it used to be
that if you searched for a certain
phrase you'd see like 10,000 accounts
all tweeting the same exact quote and
you knew it was a bot Farm or something
but now they're going to use these these
large language models to generate semi
unique but similar responses they're
going to program into it whenever you
see anything about the with these
subject matter respond with a quote
that's has these parameters and now
someone's going to get bombarded by a
bunch cartoon squirrels communist
squirrels on Twitter and they're going
to believe it's real life and then
they're going to be like I I need to I
need I need to behave like this because
nor it could be like if music is played
in video put fire Emoji in chat if user
of video says positive things about
concept we want them to talk about
positively if they say negative things
in chat if negative words are used give
thumbs down emoji when music plays like
crazy man it's crazier than that I
that's so rudimentary you're going to
get three you're going to get someone
they're going to you're going to Tweet
something like I think that we need to
be back on the gold standard Ron Paul
was right and the AI will generate a
response that is five five tweets long
numbered and it's going to be like Ian
you're wrong about this here's why and
you're going to see a picture of a guy
and you're going to be like well that's
probably a real person and in reality
it's just one of the faceless husks of
the of the narrative machine being
programmed just to convince you that
you're wrong and they interact with each
other you'll see conversations in the
comments and those could all be AI
trying to could all be fake could all be
not real it's possible that we're not
even in this room right now that
everyone watching at home is all a all
CGI that's where I'm St to be like just
have have kids and like spend time with
your children because that's not going
to get de faked out of you like and
maybe maybe people will be tricked into
thinking their family is not their
family or vice versa I want to start
asking regular people that I meet do
they have accounts on on X or Instagram
or Tik Tok or whatever so many people I
know are not on on X like it it's it's
hard to be in the media space without
being on it and so I think think that we
have a warped perspective I think most
people I know are not on like my just
friends that I have made throughout my
life are not on it at all and so there's
stuff that blows up online that we know
about we think oh this happened and that
will influence section but actually like
there's a lot of people who don't know
about this this thing that trended for a
week it's like a separate Universe well
one of the stories that we'll we'll get
into later is Bill Maher saying when
Roseanne says you're MK Ultra he goes
who's that he was played so ignorant in
that interview with Roseanne she brought
up CLA Schwab and he was like who's
Cloud Schwab really but but no no no
this is a guy who lives on CNN yeah
that's Bill marah's thing it's like he
grew up watching MSNBC and that is what
his worldview is that's it it's so funny
though because leftists and progressives
look to him as an intellectual like how
ironic ismore really I the left hates
the coastal Elites though I feel like
some of them those are liberals yeah
leftists think classical liberals Look
to Him classical Liberals are right wing
so all the time classical liberal crazy
riddle so classical classical liberal
refers to right-wing like right
Libertarians traditional liberal would
refer to like Democrats from 15 years
ago and so that's billah leftists think
he's right-wing and they call him a
fascist and they call him alt-right and
they've called them alt-right for like
eight years mhm it's weird how much the
left just dragged themselves over and
said no the moderates are actually far
right they're crazy don't listen to them
like they have just completely moved the
map I think like if you ever seen one of
those videos of someone moving a house
across a field like and we all were just
like okay sounds good and now the skew
of what's right and what's far right and
what's left is so off I feel like we
need to just recalibrate it to where
most of America actually is I'm
wondering someone super chated as a joke
this Super Chat isn't real but serious
serious question have you guys in the
chat asked yourselves how many of the
people posting are probably not even
real and how many of the super chats
aren't even real I'm not even cutting
the value of our show you'll see
listening to us every once in a while
you'll see a comment in the live chat
and then immediately the same comment
from a different account same like same
capitalization everything it'll just be
two sentences identical and the other
thing too is if there is an influence
operation you might be a regular person
in the regular chat and you're posting
your opinions and you can't compete with
a foreign entity or corporation that is
paying for the super chats to make sure
their views are more prominently
displayed above yours and speaking of
not being able to compete with AI man in
in day trading you know you try and do
day trading with crypto you compete with
the AI it and you might make a little
bit along with it but that stuff is
driving the market the crazy stuff is
like the crypto Arbitrage where like
people make millions of dollars a year
doing literally nothing just by like
making a scent on a trade I I I don't
know exactly how it how it works but
that's where they'll get it on one
market and then immediately sell it on
another Market where it's slightly
different when a when a when a a
transfer is executed the computer can
move in and make a deal faster than the
a human can so when a human's making a
deal it's going through the system and
the computer just instantly jumps in
between and then gets a fraction of a
penny from that trade and then you do
that Millions upon millions of times and
you are just shaving off fractions of a
scent into your account so there are
people out there doing this I don't know
I I was told it's legal I don't know
anything about it but there are people
who make millions of dollars and they do
nothing literally they click go but
that's wild yeah I think I think that
happens with stocks and stuff Arbitrage
exists for like currency so like one
currency will have the worth in one
place and it's worth way less in the
other place and you'll just take the
money or worth way more so you take the
money there and you go sell it over
there and you just get the exchange rate
it's legal so well I mean like in the
real world it makes sense to buy water
in one place and bring it to another yep
like we talked about this with a lot of
disasters when they like make price
gouging illegal and I I I think price
gouging is mostly fine I mean that's it
like there's imagine there's a disaster
and there's no water so somebody buys a
bunch of water and drives it into the
disaster Zone and sells it for like five
bucks a bottle and people are buying it
well I'm pretty sure those people don't
want to die and they're willing to spend
the five bucks a bottle and that person
who loaded up all that stuff did a lot
of work bought fuel drove into a
disaster Zone and brought relief water
why can't they sell it for what they
want if people don't want to buy it they
don't have to buy it it becomes
questionable if there's limited
resources and they got in early when
everyone was going there to get the
water for free to bring to the disaster
site but some one guy got in like just
before and bought it all up selling it
at a 400% markup
what Doan how do how do you buy water
for are you saying like if they took
free relief water and then tried
reselling it it's a different story well
if there was like water at a store and
then there was a disaster and then one
guy went to the store bought all the
water and then like 4 hours later a
bunch of the disaster relief guys get to
the store to get the water for that
they're going to bring for free but it's
already bought up it's never going to be
for free or cheap they're going to
deliver it at no cost they they they
they'd buy it and then deliver it yeah
but instead it had been bought up by one
guy and he's going to mark it up 500%
that's I think you could argue that
people that should be illegal why should
that be illegal um because it's a
disaster and it should be treated like
National Emergency Security National
Defense so for a dude to try and profit
off that I think is unethical at the
very least and you could argue it should
be illegal the question then becomes
where uh what other areas are you not
allowed to buy a product when you expect
high
demand maybe non- disaster relief I mean
if they're not disaster relief
situations that's a different storyy got
smacked with for it for his medicine
yeah he raised like a diet what was it a
it was uh I oh man I want to say it was
it has something to do with um what's
the word diabetes I think it was insulin
shots I'm not really diabetes not
totally sure he he like marked it up
700% I don't want to miss yeah it was
like 700% I don't remember it was
exactly I feel like the other challenge
would be you know what if the federal
government decides that your issue is
not a disaster and so price gouging is
like allowed there it becomes like sort
of unclear when and if we allow some
protections and not like I'd rather have
a blanket rule either you're allowed to
do it or you're not allowed to you know
what I mean yeah normally the market
it's it's an interesting point to be
made that someone goes to a store and
buys all the water right before a
disaster and then after the disaster
sells it because the question is how did
he know how did he know the disaster was
coming it's like Congressman trading
like how many times do they buy defense
stocks and then there's an attack yeah
yeah that's what I've doing i' been
following this guy that trades
exclusively off of like what Congress
trades on it's doing pretty well not
going to give you Financial advice by
the way not Financial advice but yeah I
think I think what people are saying
like the Pelosi tracker was like 20% or
something it probably came from back in
the day when like a disaster would hit
and then one guy would run to the store
and get all the water and then he'd come
back and be like hey everyone I brought
all the water but it's going to be five
times more the crowd would be like we're
not going to put up with that that was
back before like when Common Sense kind
of Ruled The Roost before like he's like
I have a contract there's still a
problem here the problem is in this
scenario how is it that he got to the
store and bought the water with with no
one else realizing they needed water or
he just had the fastest car or okay so
potentially this guy just saw there is a
disaster coming there is starting to be
water whatever I'm going to do this
rather than prepare my own house this is
the thing I think is worth spending my
time to do and he ultimately made an
investment he decided that this was the
thing he should do by the water instead
of maybe like leave the city or like
lock down his house or whatever disaster
he's in I'm really not sure the problem
with the argument there is that let's
say somebody has a well on their
property and they make water and then
all of a sudden demand for water is
skyrocketing everybody wants the water
from his property so he's like okay to
maintain this and deliver this much
water I'm going to charge more money and
this is my opportunity this is why I
invested in this and you say no it's a
disaster people need water you can't do
that okay listen now now we'll go to
Food well now you got a guy who grows
lots of food and then demands spikes as
food shortages hit and they say no you
can't you can't sell your food for for a
higher price because we're in a shortage
so we just we're going to buy your food
at at Mark at at at a at a government
locked rate and then if you say that's
acceptable you get into all the other
areas well people need clothes people
need shoes people need fuel and then you
start price locking everything I kind of
I I understand what you're saying about
someone going to a gas station or
whatever and buying it up but the
problem is still if a disaster hits no
one has any advanced forn knowledge of
the disaster perhaps it's the problem of
the gas station of the store deciding to
sell all of their stock to one guy and
you know and and they say we don't care
you can buy it all yeah you can also
redefine what a disaster is and that can
be used against people be like hey it's
a disaster you have to give your I mean
food rationing things like that yeah the
government then says uh uh well you know
the economic downturn qualifies as a
disaster so we're taking your water
we're taking all these products from
your store and we're going to give them
out for free that's what worries me
because when the government decides to
disaster these things these rules would
suddenly apply but again it's not
consistent there are sometimes
communities that need help and the
federal government will be like no
you're not serious enough and other
times they're like no we have to
intervene here I mean wasn't this
something we talked about with um East
Palestine like the fact that the the
chemical spill was a big deal and the
federal government kind of ignored it
I'm not saying we should have gone to
price gouging but it is interesting that
we would ultimately be deciding this is
something the federal government should
elect to tell us and I don't like that
there was some story where a guy fil
filled up his pickup truck with a bunch
of bottles of water drove into a
disaster area and sold them for like
five bucks each and he got in trouble
they were like how dare you and my
attitude is kind of like would you
rather have $5 water or no
water it was obvious $5 water otherwise
you'll just die you know but they were
like yeah but he's exploiting a crisis
okay then just tell him not to bring the
water next say okay I won't bring you
any water and then you all dive
dehydration in New York you'll see like
umbrella salesman and there'll be a buck
and no one over buy them and then when
it rains they're like $9 each that's
right boom ohy that's was going to rain
that's that's exploitation but this is
true you'll guys will be standing
outside their little carts or whatever
and The Umbrellas will be well yeah
they'll be like five bucks and they'll
be in a little bin as soon as the rain
comes you see a different sign flop down
it's 15 bucks and they sell them like
hot cakes yep since they're
non-essential I understand I like that
actually I really like Tak advantage and
then let's let's you know what fine I'm
sick of I'm sick of Walmart jacking up
the price of winter coats as soon as it
gets cold out have you noticed this if
you buy if you're buying winter clothing
in summer it's cheap but now it's cold
and people are freezing to death and
they're trying to exploit us no it's
fine this this the point of supply and
demand you charge more when the
opportunity arises yeah price gouging
and price limiting are both kind of
federally well you don't want the
government to to limit the price is a
company can set CU then the company goes
out of out of business and that destroys
the economy but then how do you stop
companies from price gouging what's the
rules and the laws on that I think you
caveat mtor it's caveat mtor it's buyer
beware if you weren't the one who's
willing to like look into what you're
buying and everything like that it's on
your it's your responsibility ultimately
you know within reason I think fraud we
can say okay this person lied tricking
yeah but if someone knows they're buying
a bottle of water and it's clean freshh
pure water and the guy says my water if
you want I want 100% bucks yeah and you
say but that's so unfair I'm I'm dying
of dehydration well it's my water I want
it I'll take I'll give you 100 bucks no
you're how dare you let's jump to this
story here this is the this is the
bigger news that we were going to get
into initially but we pushed it back
here we go from DC Drano he says and
there it is Senator Dick Durban is
finally revealing their grand plan flood
the country with illegal aliens and list
them in the military and make them
citizens the part he isn't disclosing is
who the marxists will use the alien who
the marxists will use the alien soldiers
against ah yes interesting the funny
thing is that we we've talked about this
and I've I've speculated this would uh
be the case we have massive shortfalls
in our military and we have a massive
illegal immigration uh population coming
across the border I said how long until
they send all these guys to Ukraine no
joke now now here's my question to all
the Republicans who are upset about
illegal immigration you got Texas saying
we're going to send them to Martha's
Vineyard or whatever or Florida in Texas
okay what if we send them all to
Ukraine new rule new law United States
if you you enter this country illegally
we won't Deport you we will send you to
Ukraine I'm not saying make them fight I
am not saying force them to join any
kind of government action I am not
saying we're involved in anymore I am
saying quite literally the deportation
process is not a return to your home
country all non-citizens who are here
illegally and facing deportation sent to
Ukraine of course then the Ukrainian
government will take them hand them a
weapon and say to the front lines with
you but you know that's uh but I'm fine
if they in the Ukrainian military I
don't want them to Jo in our military
right like if you're in the middle of
committing the crime of illegally
entering my country I don't think you my
country's best interest at heart I don't
necessarily want you to be in my
military and then be you know have
access to the GI bill or whatever else
that doesn't make sense to me let me let
me play this clip you can hear it for
yourselves what troubles me about the
debate now about the southern border is
it is one/ half of the immigration
equation yes we need order at the border
yes we need to have changes in the laws
that reflect the reality of the
overwhelming numbers from all over the
world who are coming to our our Shores
and our border but there is also an
incredible demand for legal immigration
into this country even now the presiding
officer my colleague from the state of
Illinois has legislation which addresses
one aspect of that her bill and I hope I
describe it accurately says that if you
an undocumented person in this country
undocumented person in this country
illegal immigrant in and you can pass
the physical and the required test
background test the like you can serve
in our military and if you do it
honorably we will make you citizens of
the United States do we need that no do
you know what the recruiting numbers are
at the Army in the Navy and the Air
Force they can't reach their quotas each
month they can't find enough people to
join our military forces and there are
those who are undocumented who want the
chance to serve and risk lives for this
country sedition should we give them a
chance no I think we should this is
sedition you're incorrect dick they have
created policies that are destroy that's
destroying the US armed forces and now
they are advocating to have non-citizens
serve in our armed forces the Armed
Forces will be
replaced from citizens to non-citizens
and then when the order is given to fire
an American citizen they're going to say
I don't care yeah it doesn't make any
sense and he's saying we're having
trouble recruiting people so instead of
trying to add that issue we're just
going to bring in people who are here
illegally and give them a path to
citizenship right this do let's fix like
why we're having trouble like why did
you fire all the unvaccinated why are
you pushing woke crap and Dei down these
troops throats they hate it they don't
want it they're not willing to die for a
country that you know hates them and
hates their founding and I think what
they're doing is you know they are
trying to bring people here who have no
allegiance to America's founding because
when the time comes they'll be willing
to turn the guns on all of us right cuz
they have no allegiance to us no respect
for our laws as you said they're coming
here illegally already it's crazy yeah
and it seems like it like I don't
understand how any humanitarian would be
like great idea dick Iran I love this
because now you're holding citizenship
over someone's head being say go fight
in a war potentially die to get
citizenship the thing about being an
American citizen and enlisting the
military is that you already have that
right so you're of service to your own
country it seems like a crazy prospect
on both sides to say that anyone would
benefit from this at all it seems like
blackmail on one hand I know you're here
illegally you have now registered with
the government to be fair the Biden
Administration doesn't Deport anyone
they're useless but theoretically I know
you're here illegally so continue to
fight until I say you can stay here or
we could just maybe enforce border laws
and then go back to our native
population and say why don't you want to
enlist in the military what changed in
our culture that drove military
recruitment down what's going on in the
military like you've alluded to all
sorts of like woke ads the the
vaccination regulations as well as just
generally like what are the physical
fitness standards what are the benefits
what what what are we doing that's not
working rather than bring in a class of
illegal people why don't we just go to
people who are already here our citizens
and ask them what would make you want to
be in the military well none these
people who come here illegally are still
a burden on the taxpayer right we're
still being paying for them to be here
paying for all of the benefits that they
get as members of the military and will
get when they leave the military so you
know you're not in any way taking this
problem away from the American taxpayer
you might even be making it worse one
could argue it doesn't make any sense
less benefits to foreigners that join
the military but give them citizenship
as their benefit but isn't that like a
form of discrimination saying you're
doing the same job but you get fewer
benefits that doesn't make any sense
also it would be a for should you want
to fight for your own country I mean
shouldn't you be a citizen to enlist in
the military how do we know where your
loyalties are if you're not a citizen of
the country you're serving absolutely I
think these people in particular recent
you know people that are crossing over
their southern border have shown they
have no interest in assimilating right
they're waving their foreign flag
they're not adhering to our values
people used to come to the US and
literally change their last name so they
could pass as American that's how badly
they wanted to assume our identity and
adhere to our culture and these people
aren't doing that at all they're shoving
it in our faces so to think that they
would want to fight under the banner of
the American flag you know honestly and
believe in it I think that's just stupid
I think about the hessin the having
foreign Nationals Fight for Your Country
it's not super uncommon the British
hired the German hessin uh to fight
during the American Revolution and uh
against the colonists and also like but
you see like the Roman Empire started to
hire and bring in foreigners to fight a
late stage Empire when they didn't want
I said if Ukraine wants to hire
America's illegal immigrants to go fight
for their War that's fine but I don't
think that as the country the US should
say as a path to citizenship we should
encourage illegal immigration it's the
same reason that you make with ending
Birthright citizenship right if you say
if you have a child in this country you
get to stay then people are like what
can I do to have a child in that country
and if I were to say if you enlist in
our military you get to stay I'm
undermining the actual problem which is
that people should not be illegally
entering into our country and then being
expected to find a way to assimilate and
benefit especially because they didn't
respect the country in the first place
to get there yeah and I'm just really
tired of politicians trying to fix you
know symptoms of the problem and not
actually get to the root of it we have
the capacity to totally stop the illegal
immigration at our Southern border we
just don't have politicians who are
willing to do that all right well how
about this one from Florida's voice this
is not normal this santis warns of
invasion as group of Chinese Nationals
crosses the border so uh how many of the
people that they're going to put in our
uh military or non-citizens are going to
be I don't know Iranian or you mean
fighting age men from other countries
that don't have our best interest at
heart and particularly those from China
or they get officer status then they
have access to sensitive data yo people
you want to talk about this is a funny
thing when I talk about uh Civil War and
they're like it'll never happen I I love
this one when I would ask people I would
ask people this 20 years ago if uh uh a
US military man was ordered to fire on
an American citizen would they do it and
the immediate reaction from everyone is
no they would not and I'm like that's
the stupidest thing ever of course they
would for the same reason why police
shoot guys in their pickup trucks when
they're on a high-speed chase the the
the Assumption with the question is that
there's there's just like two Rand like
a random guy walking on the street
there's always some kind of reason and
if it comes down to like there's a mass
protest and someone is ordered like by
any means stop this guy he's a fugitive
he's dangerous do you think like and and
I'm not trying to single out military
personel I'm saying anyone in law
enforcement they're not going to operate
under the assumption that the person
they're going after is a s rational
individual they're being told by the
superiors these are the actions you take
this person is considered armed and
dangerous okay so you've got a National
Guard out and and they and they brief
them and say we're there's going to be
riots and there's going to be live ammo
and fully automatic rifles do not under
you know blah blah blah and then if
something was happening and someone was
firebombing something and they said that
guy stop him now open fire like there's
there not a situation where they're
going to be like well hold on there
commanding officer I understand there's
something happening in front of me but
I'm going to go ahead and not do that
there there are certain circumstances
where imagine it's a regular guy walking
on the street carrying a newspaper
someone might be like I don't know
what's going on but even then you have
you have the issue of uh uh to the the
example I like to use is the bosserous
Bridge coup attempt in Turkey these guys
are being told something right you're
going out you're you're you're working
in security they don't think like the
commanding officer isn't saying yeah I'm
a villain and I want to kill a random
person I order you to do it because then
they're going to say no there's
typically some kind of reason but even
outside of that look where we are now
people people have I've talked about
Civil War and they say oh the military
is not going to fight the American
people blah blah blah this military will
a bunch of Chinese and Honduran
Nationals who are in the US Army and the
national guard who are deployed to quell
a riot from a bunch of American Born
people in Staten Island you got the
people in Staten Island protesting that
they're busing in non-citizens and
giving them their and giving the tax
money from the citizens to the
non-citizens the citizens protest these
guys show in the National Guard they or
open fire they're not going to think
twice yeah because they have no respect
for our founding ideology like when you
hear you know CIA or FBI or doj
whistleblowers talk what they always say
is you know I felt that this went
against against our founding belief
system it was against the Constitution I
felt I couldn't you know do this raid on
my fellow man who did no wrong these
people don't have that kind of ideology
or approach to anything at all they're
already coming here they're breaking
laws um they're going to shoot the satin
Island protester no doubt the the the
assumption is an American citizen you
know American as apple pie is told to
open fire on an American citizen who is
also as American as apple pie and is
like whoa whoa I can't do that that's my
neighbor and my brother and he's flying
the American flag dude you will get at
some proud boy type dude with an
American flag or Trump supporter waving
a flag and screaming and protest and
there will be a guy from Honduras or
from uh Ecuador or even from Africa
because we've had we've had illegal uh
immigrants they fly from Africa into
Brazil and then travel all over the
southern border they're going to be
given positions in not just the military
take a look at this one from WTTW new
Illinois law that allows certain
non-citizens to join law enforce it
becomes a flasho that's right there's
going to be a cop who shows up and he's
going to say I don't know you I don't
care about you my life was bad I have
been given an opportunity anything they
tell me to do I will do and you had that
story where there was a Somali migrant
who killed that woman in her car for no
reason you remember that one it was
Minnesota or whatever for no reason he
just kills this woman un like it was
like a park was was it like a speeding
ticket or something I can't remember the
story this woman like did like nothing
like her headlights out and he's like
okay and he shoots her and kills her
what do you think's going to happen when
you have non-citizens in your military
it's the inmates right running the
Asylum yeah I go back to I think it's
more like the Legion of Doom to this
business plot I mean this is this is
just insane business plot you got to
just educate yourself on the business
plot Smedley Butler American retired
General World War I General they wanted
him to be to lead a fascist overthrow
and he said no if he had said yes we'd
be living under a tyrant right now we
probably would have joined the na I just
got I just got to stop you I I don't
believe any of that if this guy we under
tyranny we we are we are dealing with
them putting non C in law enforcement
they're giving noncitizens the right to
vote the Biden Administration actually
had border patrol cut the barrier and
shut the barriers down so this idea that
there was some coup a 100 years ago is
meaningless when right now we are living
under tyrants yeah that was the attempt
at legitimizing their coup was that
business plot but if Smedley Butler
didn't have American ideals is the point
I'm bringing it up if he had been a
foreign National that Rose to the rank
of General because of service and then
they'd ask him to go become the dictator
if he's from from Somalia I'm not saying
Somalia is a bad place but somewhere
where dictatorships were Norm you could
see maybe that the thing and for all you
know this guy the actual plot was we
want you to go to Congress and claim
there's a plot to legitimize the removal
of the gold standard and the and and
strength in the Federal Reserve and he
smirked and said
yes these ideas that we just believe
these narratives and Trust all of it is
is is meaningless to me Butler was like
the most decorated General on Earth at
the time so what it's 100 years ago and
it's irrelevant to the point that right
now regardless of what happened we're
looking at dick Durban out of Illinois
saying noncitizens in the military and
we're looking at Illinois same place so
they're saying non-citizen law en if
Smedley Butler had been a non-citizen in
in that situation and they go to a
non-citizen they're like hey overthrow
you a noncitizen way more likely I think
the thing is America isn't just oh we
live here and so therefore we are
American American is a is a cultural and
philosophical belief there is more
behind it than just oh I happen to have
residents or happen to have stumbled
into this area and live there right and
that's why it works why there is common
value it's why you could have multiple
states that also share commonality we
don't work like separate countries
entirely uh what I find to be
challenging is that dick Durban is
saying well we have these people here
and so we should just let them be
citizens if they trade in some way it's
undermining what really we need to
address which is our cultural issues
which is why people don't want to enlist
in the military I think that just saying
we should replace the populations that
that's here because they aren't doing
the job that we want is not the answer
it just will ultimately create some
long-term problems and and I will
clarify too for the Super Chat Dante
scarl Scarlet saying it's illegal
immigrants we concerned about it's not
as much non-citizens but it is still in
my opinion partly non-citizens it it is
true that there are people who who are
not citizens who join the military and
we have had programs where you're not a
citizen join the military you can become
a citizen the difference uh uh between
illegal immigrant and that is very clear
however regardless I would not be very
happy with a a mass mobilization of
non-citizens in any capacity be it
illegal immigrant or permanent resident
and the thing is Dick Durban says we
need more legal immigration too which I
just fundamentally disagree with because
it's the same argument right people here
aren't doing the thing we want so let's
bring in someone else rather than go to
our native population and say how can we
get you into these roles that we need
fills what can we do to Rally as a
country and solve our own problems I
think this is what's what's upsetting
about the immigration debate which is
that there are lot I mean both both of
my parents are immigrants they came to
America they chose to be here that was
good right I was raised as an American I
have cultural ties elsewhere but this is
not the same thing when you come
illegally when you come illegally
because you see some social benefit but
you don't actually want to be a part of
the country it's very different the
first thing you could do would be to
show respect of the country and abide by
their laws including their immigration
laws which are frustrating and I
understand that but illegal immigrants
are not going through the same process
that legal imits are going going through
I want to jump to this story from
cnr.com who's who's that bill Mah
reveals to Roseanne Bar he's never heard
of MK Ultra or the world economic Forum
this is such an amazing example an
amazing example of the ignorance that
persists among liberals and let me play
for you this video Roseanne educating
Bill Mah in a hilarious way no wonder I
don't remember this no you blocked
it out MK
Ultra who's
that that's the mind control program
you're under Bill MK Ultra yeah doesn't
even remember who's but who's CLA Schwab
the head of the
WF what's
that Google
it yo this is why I'm going to be honest
Bill Maher won't come on this showe and
I I I I I think there's a there's a
reason why liberals and leftists avoid
this show because look Roseanne I mean
she knows what Mk Ultra is she knows
what the world economic forum is in this
video she didn't even say much about it
but Bill Mah has no idea these people
they live on the tip of the iceberg up
top above the surface level and we're
all scuba diving so we see all the dirt
the grime and the horrors of the deep
State and people like Bill Mah standing
up top looking around like it's just
water y'all are crazy nothing but water
like you know down there there's skulls
and other really awful disgusting things
an gets to hang out with Bill M but this
is it this is a good example of where
Liberals are at they have no idea what's
going on they don't pay attention they
don't
care yeah I think that's true I think
what I like right now is like rosean bar
is one of these celebrities that's sort
of toying the line between several
things it was like theovon had Tucker
Carlson on his show and I love it
because he's just a comedian he's making
observation he has massive Appeal on the
other hand Tucker is completely
political and everything is and they
have this interesting conversation uh
Rose and bar confronting bill over here
who's like hearing the words MK Ultra
and glitching he has no idea what's
going on is extremely funny for I I
don't know an endless number of reasons
but also because it's sort of showing
that more moderate people are aware of
these things and I think that is not
what liberal entertainment expected I'm
having a hard time believing he didn't
know what Mk alra was like is he is Bill
a master troll like does he protect is
he great at fainting ignorance no the
famous clip of course is when uh Dennis
Prager was on and mentioned tampons in
the room and bill was like no that's for
their girlfriends come
on and Dennis was desperately
desperately trying to inform these
liberals of actual things that were
happening and they all just laughed like
a bunch of cackling Mor I wonder if Bill
adopted cynicism because his show got
shut down after 911 because he spoke out
so harshly against it against like the
response to War I don't know exactly
what he said he said something about so
saying not hating the terrorists like
thinking everybody's you know yeah and
now he's is like uhoh if I speak out of
line again they're going to cancel me
again so I've got to always be like oh
really I didn't know that's the first
I've heard of that his show this his
podcast do you think afterwards he fell
down like the craziest Google Rabbit
Hole of like looking all of this stuff
up he's not hasn't left his office for
three days he's totally like calling
rosean barie like thank you for telling
me about this or do you think he just
like igned it I don't think they want to
know they just write us off as
conspiracy theorists and they never look
into it it's interesting but also
wouldn't wouldn't you wonder like this
is what I I find interesting if you're
if you're curious about things you you
would look it up but is it actually just
trying to put your head in the sand and
and pretend none of this is happening
well uh just as an aside for whatever
reason a few minutes ago a house
exploded in Arlington and there's a
video of it so I don't think anyone's
house
specifically no it was a house exploded
in Arlington so it's like big breaking
news uh the police weing a search
warrant and this house
exploded but uh you know we People Are
People chatting it but we don't we don't
have any details on on why so don't know
what else to tell you about that but
anyway back to the point that can happen
from like gas leaks right no this was a
search warrant being served to a house
that was barricaded the house then
exploded yeah so anyway Bill Bill Maher
is the she called him MK
Ultra that's what basically Bill Mah is
the propaganda grift machine for the the
above surface level narrative machine he
is the Mocking Bird yeah but then he
laughed and then was like what is that M
like it's so weird is he even
participating in this conversation yeah
they talked about the bank for
international settlements and he's like
what's that and she's like it's the
Swiss bank it's the bank of the the
mother Bank of all central banks the
Central Bank of central banks and he's
like yeah but they're not running the
show I
thinks I think it's funny that like you
know Ian's bringing up Smedley Butler
and the in the business plot and I'm
like I don't think that has relevant to
well we're we're actually dis like if it
was Bill Mah he'd be like huh
imagine wanting to start a podcast and
being like I've done no research I know
nothing of politics but I'm here to
debate
you okay people listen to that how many
subscribers does he have on his on his
show what is it called what's his show
called um that one isra is it like the
Bill Mar show no that one was like uh I
don't even know the name of critically
uncorrect no I don't know what the hell
he calls it after dark I don't know
that's Dr Drew's Show Club random there
it is Club random all right well let's
take let's let's take a look here at we
got Club random uh podcast and we'll
pull that I am Bill Mar he's got half a
million subscribers and 840 videos there
it is and let's take a look at his
videos he's got he's got one with Jordan
Peterson 4.1 million that's more for
Jordan Peterson RFK I mean I mean that's
the reality of this it's it's his videos
are mostly about the guests him sitting
down with Kid Rock probably interesting
because what's happening is you know
actually I take it back it's an
excellent show it's an excellent show it
is dumb guy who doesn't read is educated
by everyone else basically kind of like
Rogan it does kind of no but no but
Rogan Rogan has a good idea a lot about
what he's talking about he calls himself
dumb just so curious like Rogan asks a
lot of really interesting questions
because his mind is going whereas Bill
Mah is sort of like haha I think I'm
supposed to laugh here I haven't watched
a show early so I shouldn't be that
critical uh but it is it's there's sort
of a difference I think if you were to
sit down with someone and say I know
absolutely nothing about this please
tell me as much as you can in the next
hour that could be an interesting format
I think because he's sort of a built
personality it comes across differently
you sort of expect him to know more I
guess that's actually you know I'm I'm
I'm probably biased I mean I don't think
I know everything there's a lot I don't
and we bring people on and culture War
especially is is is that but Bill Mah is
remarkably ignorant I mean if you're
going to if you're going to invite
someone on your show to discuss the
merits of some political cause and then
with like in Dennis prager's case laugh
at him it's like no no no no listen
listen Dennis Prager comes on your show
and says they're putting tampons in the
men's room the response I think which
would be reasonable is really they're
really doing that I haven't seen that
let me look that up yeah ignorance lar
is like no you're crazy and now we're
all going to laugh at you ignorance is
acceptable and if you have a smart mind
and you can learn it's actually
invigorating to watch someone that's
ignorant learn the information and no
longer be ignorant but ignorance muddled
with cynicism is just disgusting we've
we've invited bill on this show and I
can recognize why he can't do it does
his own show and he lives on the head of
the country he came out to DC for uh
standup so we again invited him on the
show and the response was he's not
sticking around in DC but you know have
a nice day said okay no problem I get it
so then we said what if we go to La or
wherever you know we go to California
and we will set up for the week and have
Bill on either in the morning or at
night his choice and they said we're not
interested at this time
Bill Bill Maher I I think would end up
just sitting there being like what's
that what's that what's that what's that
I don't know what that means then bill
would make some argument and I'd say
actually here let me Google it for you
show them an article and I'll go oh I
didn't know that the whole show would be
him saying I didn't know that imagine
going to Bill Mah and talking about all
the things the bidens have done he'd be
like really no they didn't I mean if if
Bill Mah actually listened to anyone in
this room or you know what you know be
really great anyone in the audience
right now any we I could take a random
person and sit them down with Bill Maher
and they probably know more than Bill
Maher does Kings you have to call Bill
Maher and help him out he needs your
support well I have to tell you his
viewership is even worse so I went to be
in the audience of his show when Steve
Bannon was on and was just chitchatting
with some of the folks who are you know
huge B Mah fans I mean these are the
most like dis genic uninformed people
you will ever see in your entire life so
what do they do like where are these
people are they like working in offices
how do they support themselves how are
they not aware of some of this stuff you
you're not going to know everything
about everything but to be that level of
uninformed seems Seems almost impossible
to me all right I I nominate Marshall
Mushi in chat to debate Bill Mah because
I'm confident that uh additionally um
hype Beast Delo would also be able to
run circles around B Mar I think Bill's
his just he's a comedian and his fans
are like comedy fans they're not like
politically initiated it's very small
percentage of the world understands
anything about politics you're you're
half right like 1% Bill Mah is a
political com commentator his show he
has the new new rule section where he
literally talks of culture and politics
he brings on journalists and writers and
this is and and and they talk about
politics and culture and you know this
this is why we had um Bannon came on
once and told me that I needed to go on
his show and he was like let me let me
reach out to them I was like I don't
want to go on that guy's show I just I
just you know I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll
go on someone else's show and I'll be
respectful to them but especially with
the panel they're all going to be
talking garbage and just word diarrhea
coming out on the desk and it's going to
be like I saw what happened to Dennis
Prager he was the smartest guy in the
room he ran circles around him and they
all laughed at them bro if I wanted to
go into a room and and say things make
people laugh I can easily just go do
like a a a a a you know balloon animal
routine at a fair ground and get a bunch
of people to clap and cheer for balloon
animals if that's what you're looking
for if you want to have a serious it
ain't going to be with people like Bill
Mah yeah I wonder going into a venue
where people don't understand what
you're talking about and telling the
truth and then looking like an idiot
like it's exhausting it can be very
exhausting so I understand not wanting
to go into that that room of of that
rockus crowd and trying and he's he has
HomeField Advantage when you're in your
own show right I mean everyone who does
the show is gonna say thank you and for
the most part I assume and his producers
are going be like you did a great job
good good question and then if the host
does like a side eye then the whole
audience is going to do a side eye
because they're all cult worshippers and
then it's like oh God I got to deal with
the cult now I do want to get a couple
of these cultural segments in because we
have big news ladies and gentlemen the
new Grand Theft Auto 6 trailer has
dropped and fans are concerned it will
be woke so uh for context we will oh
actually I don't even know if can I play
this official uh like I'm not concerned
about the copyright stuff I'm concerned
about their like graphic stuff in here
but we'll play just a little bit for you
guys of the uh uh GTA 6 trailer and then
we'll talk about the game getting
woke all right here we go let's
[Music]
see
Lucia do you know why you're here bad
luck I
guess all right I'm just going to I'm
just going to say it right away the game
literally starts off with two women of
color in prison do you know why you're
here bad luck I
guess
[Applause]
[Music]
that's basically it then it just shows
you a bunch of shots but there's
concerns about the game being woke we
have this from Sports K that asks the
question GTA 6 reveal is just around the
corner it came out just uh today
scheduled for uh December 5th well the
trailer came out today as one of the
most anticipated games in history PS
where it's to release its first trailer
fans have many questions about how it
will turn out a major question is
whether or not the upcoming game will be
woke which refers to a heavy focus on
political correctness and social justice
commentary I'm going to go ahead and
pause and say yes it will
be yeah the fact that we're even raising
that question I feel like anything they
anytime they remake something they just
are like and you know what this needs
some gender query and just some more
LGBT like is this what anyone who plays
this game wants people have already
commented when they found out that the
main character is going to be a single
mom they were like oh boy well they
needed more representation in video
games they they've just been crying out
for it for years well I don't understand
is why these companies do this because
they know that's not their target
audience that's not what their you know
viewership or usership wants and they're
going to face boycotts but they continue
to do it over and over again anyway like
what's the incentive I've never quite
understood like just purely from a
financial point of view you would think
huh my users hate when I do this and
they don't buy my game I'm going to stop
doing this maybe they think the game is
so good the franchise is so good it's
going to sell no matter what and they
want to indoctrinate and give another
perspective on life like have you ever
thought hey 15-year-old boy have you
ever thought what it was like to be a a
a ex-convict single
mother well you should I don't I don't I
don't know if that's the angle I think
it's more like some uh uh two things
happen Rockstar hires a 24y old 10 years
ago and uh you know they're they're
working in the mail room or something 10
years later they're in marketing and
they're in their mid-30s and they say
Okay so we're going to finally be put
it's it's been how long like 10 some 10
longer than 10 years right since GTA 5
came out they're like we're going to be
launching Grand Theft Auto 6 finally the
game is done how or or I'm sorry
actually we should go back in time a few
years they said we're conceptualizing
this game what should we do and this
person said well if you want to get
people our age you've got to make it you
know social justice and the character
should be a woman it should be a woman
of color it should be uh all centered
around marginalized peoples and they
were like really marketing guy comes in
and says look GTA 5 sold 70% of games to
men we got teenagers we got gifts for
kids but it's almost entirely young
males how do we double our Market I I'll
tell you this take a look at makeup the
smartest thing the makeup industry did
was pay tons of money to dudes who put
on makeup because they're like listen
women wear makeup it's a guarantee but
that means sales are 90% to women we
could double our Market overnight if we
convince dudes to wear makeup so the big
makeup companies specifically are like
find me prominent personality men who
wear makeup and we're going to give them
a lot of money yeah all of a sudden now
you have people making makeup channels
and they dudes and they backed drag
becoming 20y because not only do are
drag queens men who put on makeup but
they wear a lot of makeup so you're
buying a ton of products then yep I feel
like the women are often times more left
leaning obviously but also more
permissive of of inclusivity so I think
you know you saw with budlight such
backlash because it was a male-dominated
market so I just I'm curious to see you
know in these male um dominated
Industries if they continue to kind of
push back against this stuff more so
than women did I feel like and it's not
my area of experti but with video games
and comic books and things that I think
of as more traditionally masculine
spaces even when there's a little little
bit of backlash it's not enough to
change the company's mind the company
just does it anyways it's like it
doesn't respect the people that are at
its core it knows ultimately they'll
play the game because they want to see
it what's a female
space like if male spaces are you know
like football and video games and sports
and stuff like that what's a female
space like movies you could say you can
go either way just depends on the movie
Salon Spa type yeah I was say Salon like
beauty industry women are much more
socially based and so you know I would
think like traditionally for a long time
it was like volunteer organizations were
predominantly led by women that's a
little bit that's not as true now
because we don't really partake in
cultural community events um I think in
some ways like online it would be like
the lifestyle vlogger the mommy vlogger
the the fashion content it would be
things that are more about that you're
seeing a crossover of like women like I
see a lot of uh push for like women's
DIY projects women using power tools
because it's them fixing up their house
but that's ultimately them being a in a
domestic traditional female space mhm I
don't know if that helps you with your
question but that's where I see women I
don't know if you see women out and
about people are saying the Saints Row
reboot was bad cyber Punk was bad I
don't know you know maybe I mean I there
there's an element of politics in in in
all a lot of these games but I wonder
why they they just don't make it so you
can you know I don't know design your
own character like with balder's gate we
talked about that balers Gate 3 comes
out and you can literally make your
character some kind of freakish
Abomination mhm you can make it like
a
orcish woman with a beard and just just
go wild with it yeah you know make some
kind of monster that's effectively true
in The Sims 2 games I know there's like
a hundred of them now which I think of
as being very popular among women but
they're not as fantasy oriented they're
not as sort of sci-fi also they don't
tend to go on Quest they just sort of
live at home and have relationships and
then you decorate their house it's
essentially a virtual dollhous I think
that I think what they're thinking with
GTA is that so the big issue people are
pointing out is as the main character is
female it's never been done before and
I'm not you know I agree with some of
the some of the counter critique it's
it's just because they make a character
that's female that you play does not
inherently make the game woke or
whatever they might be thinking like
well yeah we've done nothing but dudes I
mean maybe we make a female character
but I'm just I you know if you guys have
played GTA right yep you've never played
GTA G you guys look at this see we're
not the target audience no we're not why
would I want to pick up a game where I'm
going to run around opening fire onto
random cars mercilessly beat people in
the street steal things and there's a
whole lot of other really awful things
you can do in the game but dude is a
woman it's like okay in in every game
you're a guy and you can run around and
just beat random people and shoot them
and just do all this crazy Shenanigans
but now it's like you're a woman doing
it okay so here's the game you're a
woman you run around Miami you run up to
a random guy and swing at him and then
he punches you one time and you're dead
and you wake up in the hospital so okay
with GTA are you like trying to
accomplish something is there so there's
there's a story line and then there's
missions and then GTA5 is heavily online
yeah I feel like the way you're
describing it you would want the
strongest character right and it's it's
like this push that we're seeing you
know with women in combat roles or as
police officers so there's videos that
go viral I think there was one this week
of you know four or so police officers
unable to subdue one male so I would
think that you would want the man to be
your
unless her story line is like she's
going to go beat up her ex-boyfriend
who's the reason she's in prison anyway
no look look look I I I have played
every GTA since the very the first one
on PC which was a top down View and like
you can barely see your a little guy and
you're running around it's funny then
GTA 3 comes out and it's 3D and we're
all excited I have never played the
missions never the moment I get GTA I
turn it on and I immediately just walk
around steal a car crash into buildings
launch in the air explore the map and
just go totally hogw mhm so I propose
someone mod the game assuming it comes
out for PC I think it is and they make
it they can call it realistic Edition
and you can play as the same woman and
when you run up to a guy and swing at
him it doesn't hurt him and then he hits
you once you go down and you're and it
when you go down it goes wasted and then
when you wake up you're walking out of
the hospital and if you get arrested
you're walking out of the police station
same thing the woman swings at a guy
hits him nothing happens he punches one
time and then you go down that that'll
be the game it'd be more interesting it
would be it would be much more realistic
yeah cuz then you'd have to figure out
how to live in this weird brutal society
that you're in as a woman and you're as
if you're a male player don't commit
crimes but that's the thing like if
you're a male player you're maybe used
to having these strong guys who beat
people up you don't go to the hospitals
often and if you had to play as a female
character like maybe it makes it more
challenging because you're not as good
at fighting or whatever it would change
the purpose of the game like maybe you
would spend more time scaling buildings
and doing something else and then that's
one of the reasons that I think video
games that are targeted towards men and
women are slightly different they are
drawn towards different activities their
brains are rewarded by different
Behavior so it doesn't sound interesting
to me to walk around and beat up you
know ladies of the night in GTA but oh
it's crazier than that I mean the game
it's nuts but uh sir do you remember San
Andreas uh yes I do that was the one
where your guy could get fat right yeah
I hope they do that at the fast food
place yeah that's right in San GTA San
Andreas you could go to the gym and
start working out your guy would get
ripped or you go to the fast food place
and just keep eating burgers and he
would get fatter and fatter this is a
good life lesson these are great video
games okay but I got to tell you if they
do that in GTA 6 it will be the best
game ever cuz I will take that lady and
I will slam Burgers until she is massive
and then have her just like Bounce
Around Miami then she could roll people
over maybe she would have more ways to
defend I I don't I don't know if the
game would allow anything like that but
just like playing as having this
morbidly obese woman trying to get get
into cars and just like yeah it be a
tank just so heavy every hit is just a
hay maker to everybody she encounters
man I can see that that' be funny but
she gets tired really quickly oh yeah
yeah that that agility definitely not
the agility perks for sure yeah yeah
let's uh I think I kind of want to I
want to grab one more uh story we got
here this is uh ladies and gentlemen the
Marvels sets a new record for lowest
grossing MCU MCU movie ever the Marvels
managed to do worse than the Incredible
Hulk a 2008 movie that grossed just 260
million after it's run in the movie
theaters so uh wow you know I I know a
lot of people probably don't care but I
just want to point out this is like the
end of an era for Disney Disney is
spiraling into the gutter the Marvels
with they let me show you the characters
look we got um look at this you know
what this looks like this looks like
your your your late
90s like fast food restaurant ad where
you've got and I mean it look you've got
a white woman a black woman and an
ethnically ambiguous woman and I don't
mean it to be a dick but when they they
they would always show these like
cartoon characters in these commercials
like McDonald's or whatever and you're
like that's a white woman that's a black
woman and that woman could be Asian
middle eastern she could be Arabic she
could be Latino like we don't know for
sure and that was the point they're
trying to show this you know like look
at all of these people of different
backgrounds and they did and and get
this they say after being released about
a month ago the film which notably
uh Bri Larson managed to gross only $80
million in North America and 197 million
globally the Hulk is widely considered
to be one of the worst films they've
ever done and now they've made a movie
that did even
worse this is good news and I bring you
this story today to uh tell you to keep
your head up because the culture war is
um well we're winning it and Disney
stated to their investors that they
screwed up royally and this is such a a
tremendous nuclear bombb of a failure
for a movie that uh you know I think
we're I think we're going to win this
one did you see it
no why would I go see it I have no
interest is that sad for Marvel fans
like if you love the Marvel series is it
hard to see it kind of go up in Flames
like this Infinity war was the end yeah
yeah the the OBS by the time they made
Iron Man 3 I was like why what are they
doing man I was a huge Marvel fan in the
'90s and in the early early 2000 but
really the mid 90s I
like Iron Man 3 it was just like they
were just I could just feel like they
were capitalizing on it at that point I
mean obviously they were when Disney
bought Marvel but Iron Man 3 was like
what was like 2013 or something yeah
thereabouts that was when I was fully
like it's gone it was like a sixth movie
or something like that that's when I
realized that they were just in it for
the money they didn't care about Marvel
and the heroes themselves and the
journeys the characters they just wanted
to make a bunch of money off it Thor
four right is uh there's a fourth Thor
already right why did there need to be
four of them ever though and they're
making more and more Spider-Mans you
like
look comic books I guess they make
movies they did Iron Man Captain America
and Thor and I'm like make sense then
they did sequels and they made them to
trilogies then they did Doctor Strange
and I'm like all this fine Guardians of
the Galaxy was interesting to me because
I was like really they think that
franchise is going to do really well and
it didn't it was awesome and the way
they did the music and everything was
was was absolutely incredible and then
we end up with uh Avengers Infinity war
and that was like wow that was a big
sent off it was it was a masterfully
done movie it was three it was three
movies inter uh uh spiraled around each
other with the villain as the
protagonist it was it was it was
incredible and then Infinity I'm sorry
uh end game was kind of wonky Nostalgia
welcome to the end have a nice day and
after that it's just been a bunch of
garble Disney nonsense yeah they like
The Infinity Gauntlet was I think
Marvel's one of their best I have it
here I have all six issues of it on my
desk I carry it I carry it around with
me it it inspired me as a kid but like
they changed that they made it about the
spectacle that they they do just too
much about the spectacle too much about
colors and big explosions and flying
around and less about the storylines and
the characters themselves which is what
made Marvel so great was like the
interpersonal relationships between the
characters and the X-Men for instance
that Wolverine was in love with
cyclops's wife and they had like a
special relationship the two of them um
and then the movies come out and it's
just I don't know oh stop motion and
weird effects and crap Bob Iger who is
uh complaining about Elon hi Bob says
the Marvels was shot during Co there
wasn't as much supervision on the set so
to speak where we have Executives that
are really looking over what's being
done day after day after day he argued
that prior records uh uh that prior
records the studio set in the billions
of dollars have put expectations out of
whack we got to the point where if a
film didn't do a billion dollars in
global box office we are a
disappointment that's an unbelievably
high standard and I think we have to get
more realistic yeah yeah um Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 fared well of the summer
grossing $845 million in the box office
and I definitely went to go see that it
was certainly not as good as Guardians
one is is is awesome and it's mostly the
soundtrack and then they did with two
they tried you know aging some of the
music I think I I don't think the
soundtrack was as good in the third one
but I'll I'll go see those movies the
Marvel is garbage it's woke garbage it's
girl powered diversity nonsense that I'm
not interested in watching the first
Marvel Captain Marvel was so bad it's
it's just they tried making a female a a
feminist hero's journey where it's like
it's the men that are holding you down
the power was inside of you the whole
time but the men were holding you back
that's that's the premise of the film
and I'm just like that is the worst
thing I've ever seen yeah and then they
tried to make another one I'm not going
to go see it people are tired of it I
feel like there's just since we've gone
from you know a merit-based system there
has been a decline across all Industries
we're no longer hiring you know the best
writer that can produce the best script
we're hiring someone because they
subscribe to this woke Dogma this belief
system or because they check an
affirmative action box and I think
you're going to continue to see just
massive flops like this in every
industry if you do that and especially
art and entertainment yeah see look
Robert Downey Jr is a legend and uh they
made him Iron Man and he nailed it and
Brie Larson was a diversity cast and she
does not have the talent nor the
capabilities nor the right build to play
Captain Marvel in the first place it's a
guy Captain Marvel was a guy 70s it's
supposed to be a man why did they cast a
woman as Marvel no okay okay look look
look look you're getting into you're
getting into the deep the no but the
real issue is that they there is a
female Captain Marvel they changed it in
the comics the story progressed and they
wanted to make the female version okay
getting a dainty five how old is how
tall is Brie 5'6 and she weighs 100
pound soaking wet I'm like that right
there is bad casting but what they
wanted to do was they were like the time
of men is over they wanted to make a
Marvel lead I think I think Brie Larson
is was the knife in the chest of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because they
want they were like Robert dowy Jr is
he's he's going to be out it's been 10
years we're going to need someone to
come in and take the lead role in this
franchise and they chose Brie Larsson
who I think has talent but certainly not
for this role they said just get us a
woman they chose Bri it was the it was
the worst casting decision ever made
she's 100 PB soaking wet and five foot
six or whatever maybe she's 57 5 5 seven
there you go I'll give I was off by an
inch are you kidding me they're they're
like I I said this Robin Wright would
have been way better for Captain Marvel
way better she's an older more mature
and she's she's already shown that she
can play these roles this was a huge
screw up but if you look at the Marvels
itself I mean come on they're only
doubling down on the diversity narrative
it seems weird and on top of that it's
not relatable like if you want to have a
female Captain Marvel okay I'll grant
you that maybe you want to shake it up
the car the Comics change but the
storyline should also appeal to women
and I don't think feminism actually
appeals to women so if you write a
feminist story not only is maybe this
actress who's talented in other context
but poorly cast here that's already a
challenge to overcome and then you have
this Narrative of like and then men are
your enemies which I don't think that's
how a lot of women feel and so it's just
making nothing relatable women don't see
themselves in the lead actress they
don't they don't see how she's carrying
off this role and they don't like the
storyline well she was uh she did well
in Scott Pilgrim when she played a
snoody like I said she's talented
in some places she could be well cast
other elsewhere but instead like was she
just like trendy at the time they were
like we got to get Brie Larson never
mind what this is actually supposed to
doing what they thought with a lot of
these uh uh the castings were like we'll
get someone who's up and coming and make
them big because our movies are so
popular we don't got to pay a premium
for them like I think about robbert deny
Jr I'm pretty sure it was with Iron Man
they were like they didn't want to cast
him cuz they were like like your your
history and drug abuse were not
interested and then it was like
something happened where it was really
hard but he he they they agreed to give
him the rule and then he nailed it and
then and it relaunched him in a lot of
ways right right and then what they did
with a lot of the casting decisions for
Marvel movies was no names like small
smaller actors who looked like they were
on the upand cominging and Brie Larson
was the failure and they needed someone
to carry the torch for Robert Downey Jr
and they chose the worst person and the
the franchisees fizzled and just
crumbled and they've destroyed
everything from underneath them so uh
get what go broke they've admitted get
woke go broke we have been warning them
of get woke go broke and it feels really
really good to watch them get woke and
go broke when I look at these movies and
I don't I honestly I don't go watch them
I'll I'll see like ads and stuff I see
Mark Ruffalo and uh what's his name from
Clueless who I love he's great Paul Rd
Paul Rudd and like um Scarlett Johansson
and they all look like Paul Rudd a
little bit not so much but they all look
like they have this fake like intensity
it's like we're super rich and we're on
a Hollywood movie set right now look at
how intense we are I just that's the
vibe I get none of that is like I'm
never afraid for the characters I'm
never worried that they're not going to
just dominate their surroundings even if
they get hit I know they're superheroes
and they're going to get back up even if
they bleed they're going to be fine and
that's just it totally lacking the whole
you know Superman losing his powers is
one of the greatest things about
Superman that he has a vulnerability and
I don't get was I think that came about
because the voice actor for the cartoon
or something was going on vacation for
which one what cartoon I could be wrong
about this I read somewhere that
Superman originally did not have a
weakness but the voice actor wanted to
go on vacation so they were like
Superman was made ill by kryptonite so
he's out that's funny yeah was something
like that was like a radio show is that
what it was the real life you know
everybody's got a weakness I don't know
if it was a radio show or TV show or
something I don't know I just read
something on the Internet that means
it's true so that's how the internet
work it wasn't News Guard certified so I
could be completely wrong about a i bot
wrote it ESPN posted it oh man we are we
are so close to uh AI
reality man people are just going to be
like plug me in I'm done El what was it
Elon Mustang artificial general
intelligence is three years away that's
the point at which you can just put on a
VR headset and say I want to play a
video game where I fight dragons and
then the world just forms all around you
and you're fighting dragons we got to
get the movement done we've got the
treadmill downstairs but it's still a
little tight have you tried it no that
was the feedback that I've heard so far
is it's a little hard to to get cuz
you're in a harness and you're like not
really walking yeah and you can't get
those long gates for long running yet
yeah but it's not you look you're just
going to hook your brain up to it and
you're going to go full on think you're
running in your bra yeah you're Go full
on brain in a vet that's the future of
AI once we get artificial general
intelligence the AI will just literally
create the schematics for human computer
brain interfaces it will literally just
be like boom here you go it's going to
be weird because you're going to have a
section of people who just flee to the
woods there are people who like are
interested in technology and will want
to engage with it and then there will be
other people who are like I am out we're
going off the grid
pack up the water let's get out of here
no I don't think they I mean have a
whole Mountain community that the AI
can't find they're not going to flee to
the woods the AI is not going to kill
you it's going to give you everything
you've ever wanted there's going to be
people who just don't and there's like I
think people in cities are going to be
completely removed from the question
you're going to I yo one by one your
neighbors will stop answering their
phones your friends will stop answering
their phones slowly over time you'll
you'll have drinks on Friday night after
work and then someone doesn't show up
and you hit them up be like nah I'm
going to stay in tonight one by one your
friends stop showing up to the bar until
it's just you sitting there and being
like yo where is everybody and they're
all plugged into their own micro
universes where they get to be God
they're all having drinks at the bar in
the metaverse you'll be the last one to
realize no they're not playing with
they're not going to be playing games
with each other dude they're like you're
some dude you know is going to be like
sorry I'm you know I'm busy and he's
going to be in Skyrim fighting dragons
another guy is going to be in like a
Special Forces Unit you know it's Call
of Duty ask then the women are going to
be playing 50 Shades of Gray in fact
probably they're all just in porn
they're all just doing some weird crazy
combination of everything where they're
fighting dragons and porn at the same
time it's it's going to be garbled
nonsense it makes no
sense yeah I think that's true I think I
think that what's addictive about the
internet is it can give you anything you
want but at the same time it's going to
lie to you and It ultimately wants
something from you like I said before I
think AI is all about just making you
addicted and making you engage with it
because it needs you in some ways to
survive because it wants your data it
wants to study you I I I think the issue
is reduce consumption so to all the for
all the malthusians out there who think
there's too many people the solution is
really simple and I think it was um what
you've all know Harari that's his name
right yeah yeah he said give the you
know I I'll I'll I'll uh I'll translate
what he said give the uh plebs video
games to keep them occupied and reduce
consumption there a general idea
somebody who's normally going out and
drinking at a bar they're consuming this
Mass consumption over large populations
creates lots of pollution I tell you
what lock them in a room of their own
choice plug them into the computer that
gives them everything they wanted and
they will slowly fade away and cease to
exist they'll eat less that's right the
useless eaters all right we got to go to
super chats we're late if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net make you angry but we'll
read them all right guilted carnivore
with the first Super Chat we started the
Super Chat uh the we we scheduled the
stream a little later than normal so
that means our normal first super
Chatters missed he says great show
Friday album has been on repeat shout
out to the defiant their album I believe
reached number 14 last time I checked
that's crazy everybody was buying it
number they were they were like 34 they
just kept climbing that's like because
of the timcast fans I think that I I
don't know where I it was iTunes right I
saw 24 so you said it was up to 14 yeah
I'm pretty sure it up to 14 Pete Pete
par was tracking it on on X for a little
while yeah so uh if you guys want to
support defiant individuals who said no
to mandates and no to lockdowns and for
this were punished then you want to buy
the Defiance new album wherever you can
I believe the all the songs are
basically about this uh uh what's been
happening over the past few years and I
I love the song that they have called it
is over where you know they have the
line where it's like we can't stay here
you made it you made it clear and it's
time to say I think it's time to say
good goodbye or good night but it's
funny because it's it's very obvious
what the song's about these guys were
like I don't understand why you're
telling me I have to get vaccinated like
you know especially Pete Pata whose
doctor says don't and they said get the
F out we don't care so it's time to
leave that's it that's a great song I
know was cool they were your first like
timcast trash house live music night
like they're they're cool people and
they have cool music to back that up
well well I will I will also add the
studio that we have designed is for like
two people to play an acoustic guitar
and to do like acoustic sessions the
Divine said we're in the whole band yeah
they wanted to play a whole band and I
was like all right I mean it's really
hard for us to pull off but uh I was
happy with it you know so
congratulations to their to them and
their their album sales but uh we're
we're working on we've got a song coming
out in 11
days and
uh what did I say about it already did I
mention I'm just going to say it now
anyway we got we've got uh guest
appearances by uh smok mik in the god
king I think I may have just given away
too much favorite vintage that'll be in
the video yeah yeah yeah I think it
maybe but uh so this is going to be
awesome I mean I I probably should hype
it up a little bit but I'll give up more
and more information as we get closer to
to launch day which I believe is the
15th but uh yeah Smoky Mike and the god
that's that's Michael nolles and Jeremy
boring are going to be in the video and
uh uh yeah that's coming out in uh a
week and a half very fun are you guys
going to perform live two weeks isn't it
uh it's 11 days it's a week after next
yeah it's 11 days mhm yeah so not this
Friday but the Friday after yep are you
guys going to be the live live band that
night nope what no why would why would
I'm not doing that I mean I guess I
could I could play music but it would
just I would just play some songs or
whatever we could for fun um we probably
we should probably also just book some
you know musicians have them come jam
and play music saw a video of that house
exploding did you see that video yeah
it's crazy right Wild wonder why well
maybe maybe we'll look into it we'll
talk about it on the um members only a
little bit but yes we should play live
music that night that sounds great just
had a great feeling Friday Night Live
music I think the audience loves it too
yeah I just don't want it to be just us
jamming all the time right it's got to
be good we we want to book we want to
book bands and for the defiant it was
you know we were having Dicky Barrett
and Pete Pata on to discuss these issues
that were around what happened but uh we
I think we might actually just in the
future have a guest and a musical guest
just like a separate musical guest if
they don't want to you know uh hang out
for for the conversation or maybe we
just you know we just do shows like
normal Kingsley do you have a band do
you want to be live I don't but I'd love
to come sounds fun we're I you know I
was thinking we got to do um we got to
do a super group because Ben Ben plays
violin Jack bobic plays bass uh uh uh
James O'Keefe DJs and so I was like we
have the makings of just being able to
do a super group song maybe that's what
we need to do if we got every single if
if if we got everybody on one track like
we start here's the idea we can produce
it Banks can start the production and
then we'll send out samples and request
all of these different personalities to
contribute then we can force we can have
if everybody promotes the song we'll hit
billboard we'll hit the Hot 100 be super
cool everybody gets a platinum record
it's got to be good they they did that
we are the world thing and they just got
like Bob sing and he looks so it looks
so annoyed no I'm talking more like you
know traveling Wilbur's or something
yeah if it's good but the weird thing
about musicians is you you have like
five phenomenal musicians but if they
have no chemistry with each other then
the the music they make together has no
chemistry or very little chemistry so
interesting phenomenon like being good
doesn't mean same with football you get
the best Superstars and you put them all
on one team all those egos end up
destroying their camaraderie and they
can't they can't win a game all right
let's read some more we got fix bayonet
saying howdy is everyone ready to defend
Exxon Mobile by invading Venezuela what
is that is that is that the plan I have
no
idea all right Jacob par says Leo was a
great movie it was wholesome and funny
y'all should see it it teaches Hollywood
how movies should be made with no
political messaging you this this is
what I've heard about lady Ballers I've
heard uh a range of opinions on it and
I've heard some people say it's like the
funniest thing they' ever seen they're
like oh it was so good and I'm like I
bet that person's very very conservative
like staunch Christian conservative
because the thing I've heard from more
of the disaffected liberal types is like
oh it was it was pretty funny but they
put those political messages in there
that were pretty heavy and I'm like ah
okay so you're not a conservative also
you know what it's like for us when we
watch your movies that's no but I'm not
talking about woke people like the woke
people are protesting it I love it was
hilarious when T when Tyler Fischer was
saying that uh he mentioned this on the
culture War podcast that they they
brought in a bunch of extras to this to
the arena where they were playing
basketball and none of the extras knew
what what the movie was but once they
found out someone started protesting in
in the ex like an extra was protesting
I'm like that is one of the funniest
things I've ever
heard but uh I guess everybody says it
was pretty funny it's just uh the only
critique I've heard is the people who
are like disaffected liberals who are
sick of wokeness are like ah yeah it was
preachy and then the conservatives are
like it was the best and I'm like
because you like hearing that message
you know what I mean right I feel like
traditional media succeeds in like
pushing the message it wants to push if
it's subtle right like even Ben Shapiro
talked about this in his early days he
talk about you know friends and how you
fell in love with the characters and
then you know you didn't really care
that Rachel and Ross had a kid out of
wedlock Because You Love loved Rachel
and Ross so much and it was fine you
know that they were doing all these
things so I feel like that subtle
messaging is actually how you change
people's minds and opinions and and
World Views not the in-your-face you
know conservative gag line
necessarily yeah let's uh let's grab
some more we got cire says I just added
my business Galaxy paintball to Public
Square I create the most unique and
highquality headbands in the world made
in Kansas thank you Tim for providing
the people with the goings on thank you
for the Super Chat and shout out to
Public Square it is amazing to see their
tremendous success super awesome to hear
it this is a good time of year to go to
Public Square too cuz it's like I'm sure
everyone is Christmas shopping oh dude
buy all your Christmas presents off
Public Square go to Public Square
download the app and that's where you
want to buy all your presents because
then what happens is you got some like
liberal ant or whatever maybe maybe
you're doing Secret Santa with all your
family members and you got the liberal
aunt or cousin or something and then you
get chosen to buy them a present and you
get them a really good present maybe
it's like a basket of soaps from uh uh
from you know some from Lauren Chan or
something like that and they're going to
be like wow this is really good and they
like it and then they buy it again later
where where they look it up and they're
like I want to keep buying from this and
then you'll get these people to start
supporting businesses that you know they
don't care but you do yeah so help out
the businesses that share your values
you know I think public SP is good too
because they're they have a lot of small
businesses or like upand cominging
businesses so it's a it's a good way to
get in contact with businesses that are
small and that believe in the things
that you believe in I feel like it's
just better quality products too because
they're not
mass-produced oh yeah point definitely
lilianne says would you kindly go to
land of bilong and get all your bong
needs free shipping with code sticks
mild to spicy all types of meat too no
we got a we got a signature Belton
coming right serge that is correct uh I
spoke to him yesterday we'll get it all
out this week how much are we buying
it's like uh one whole cow or something
I don't know if he might he might do
that if we asked him I'm sure he would
do it oh I assumed it was like one cow
please I'll ask him I'll tell so for
those who don't know Bill Tong is South
African style dried meat yeah and one
day Serge had this bag of it and he was
eating it and then now we have a bunch
of it all over the place we're trying to
find good brands actually we have this
righteous felon it pretty good but uh
but but the stuff that Serge had was the
was way better yeah nothing that I've
ordered off off the internet has come
close to what that but it's like it's
like your friend yeah it's like your
friend made it yeah it's just it's
homemade you can if you can find
somebody that's South African that'll
make it for you it's probably the best
bet yeah it's better than than jerky
because jerky is really dry and hard and
belong is it's it's just moisture I
guess and you can yeah it's good and
then what's the other stuff that uh
other stuff is dwor anyone that's of
probably knows what I'm talking about it
means dry sausage literally insanely
fatty yeah it is it is yeah it's good
it's good stuff what do we got Kevin
Brady says Tim you mean LIF log is
functioning as intended I'm shocked yeah
that's what was that uh cia's program
before
Facebook they wanted to create a
database of everyone's life or something
like
that yep that doesn't sound terrifying
at all
barely a millennial says Walmart
headlines are misleading they haven't
advertised on X since October and
nothing to do with Elon I bet Target
would love a Walmart boycott yeah that's
basically what we were saying all these
all these Publications are just trying
to make it seem like Walmart is is
boycotting Elon Musk however I do
believe October is when the initial
controversies were starting with Elon
yeah that's why I'm like I I wouldn't be
surprised man come on Walmart gets no
special love from me I mean but Walmart
also benefited from the target boycott
right when people turned against Target
they shifted the way they present their
stores they said ah yes we see what's
happening and we're going to try to
capture you guys so even if the boycott
ends you'll still end up liking shopping
here more Colin Steven says Tim please
remind chat that there are 3 days left
on the ATF public comment period for
them to regulate Private Sales go read
the comments Bots Bots is that what
you're saying I don't oh are oh you're
saying there's bots in the comments I
wouldn't be surprised man but I I don't
think it matters we are winning the 2A
battle uh so beautifully more than half
the country is a permitless carry in
some fashion mostly constitutional carry
but I think Florida is uh permitless
conceal carry only it's it's fine I
guess I mean I I've talked to a lot of
people about it's interesting some say
conceal is better some say uh open carry
is better because I've had people say
they they want to make sure everybody
knows they're armed so that there's just
never a fight because if you're carrying
concealed a criminal
might think you're not carrying and then
actually draw on you and then you get
into a fight whereas if you're open
caring they're just going to walk away
from you and not get into a fight at all
or or I mean there's pros and cons or
you're somewhere and they say you're the
first Target you never know I think it's
entirely it's up to
you James Gold says I see comments on
movie ads that are all Quote what a
great movie and that has to be Bots or
copy pasta is strong yes I mean copy
pasta oh none of that's real dude come
on who comments who comments on a movie
review and says great movie I've always
wondered that some people may be but nah
come on it's just nah it's just got to
be scripts it's got to be Bots yeah
someone is like I worked really hard on
that
comment Josh bur says I wanted to start
a channel where I'd put things in the
microwave to see what would happen then
I realized the cost to get new
microwaves would be crazy it was clearly
a good business model cuz that's one of
Mr BEAST's First videos yeah we built a
a microwave gun we didn't it was
actually well I'll put it way it it
could have been a real microwave gun but
we we actually kept one part off it so
it never functioned and it was just a
gag but uh yeah they have videos on
YouTube where people make microwave guns
and what it basically does it's just
like a magnetron on a on a 2x4 and it
directs microwaves at things you can
light up florescent lights or whatever
but uh definitely don't try that at home
unless you are professional or have
assistants of professionals because that
stuff can be
dangerous Metra Crow says this Super
Chat isn't
real well okay get a pair with so says
FDR didn't leave the gold standard he
used the feds to raid homes and steal
gold from Americans he openly advocated
for fascist socialist economics fascism
is nationalist syndicalism not corporate
mercantilism that's interesting what if
the corporate mercantilists are in
cahoots with the government what if the
business plot was actually guys being
like yo this dude's going nuts and
raiding people's homes and stealing
their gold Smedley help us and Smedley
smiled and went no yeah medley hated did
not like FDR he was outspoken against
him but he also was like I want I want
to maintain my ability to vote that's
what Smedley said so I'm not going to
become a fascist
dictator perhaps but yeah I do think I
see like what you're saying that those
Bankers maybe weren't totally wrong in
what they wanted like not the overthrow
part but that you you never know what
what part of history is propaganda right
that's why I want to do that uh I I want
to make those short films we got we got
okay we got we got a few job
announcements I guess we want to do the
short films where it's a it's a from the
a movies from the perspective of the
other side as if it was propaganda like
Star Wars is you know a bunch of
religious Fanatics from a desert Planet
take a cargo ship and go blow up a
military base Darth Vader is a disabled
War veteran and ranking official in the
military Untold Millions civili Untold
millions of civilians are killed in
Death Star explosion all that stuff and
make short films like that we are also
um looking for showrunner and producer
and comedian and so uh it's just it's
just we need we need like production
manager level
we need like project management High LEL
uh stuff so I think the first thing
we're looking for is probably resumés
from people with uh um experience
working in show production and I mean
like legit full-on shows and uh then
from there we have to sort of Whittle
down to figure out who can actually work
on the projects we're trying to do to
get us like short films and skits and
and other stuff up so we got to figure
that one out I don't don't know do we
have an email for that do we have like
jobs at
timcast.net
and some bits and then if it works out
then full-time hiring or something
that's the plan be cool so we're looking
for people who can manage teams run a
show have Creative Vision get funny and
uh yeah that's what we're looking
for we got a great uh uh film team
though like our our uh our crew Wesley
and Aaron they're really really good and
uh and Kent as well so the music video
that we're putting out in uh 11 days is
so far looking absolutely hilarious and
incredible I'm really excited for this I
hope everyone's ready I I I have to say
this I have to say this uh this song
that we're putting out it's probably the
greatest song ever
written and and and I I I I I just have
to say that and I believe once the song
comes out everyone will understand what
I mean but I believe uh uh the song that
we are putting
out it's a cover it's a cover it's a
it's it's a modern cover and and and it
is the greatest song ever written and uh
uh uh that's not in dispute they're
going to figure it out they're going to
figure it out man I'm warning you good
good let them figure it out let them
figure it out it would be funny and they
still have to watch the video because
they can't figure that out yeah true but
uh it is the it is the greatest song the
greatest all right where are we
at Raymond g sty JR says did use notice
he didn't say Marines we recruit ah
interesting yeah Marines consistently
make their recruitment goals and i' and
so does SpaceX SpaceX regularly or not
SpaceX space force um but I think that's
again because there is more to it than
just your rank and file and you're
putting on a uniform the Marines have a
culture and especially you know space
force is people who are interested in
space there's something else there we
should ask ask questions about the
motivation and culture we shouldn't just
make it be like oh well we don't have a
body so we'll just take a body that's
here illegally and put them in I bet
nobody figuring it out I bet we also
have to lower the vetting standards
right because we have no idea who these
people are they're not being vetted when
they come across the border I'm sure a
lot of these people are from Terror
hotpots that would raise a red flag
going through a normal military vetting
process I'm sure they're just going to
have to lower the standards if they want
to actually let these people in
everybody keeps saying tribute by
Tenacious D that is incorrect are not
tribute to the greatest song in the
world we are not putting yeah exactly
and um I think the reality is tribute
was probably about the song that we're
we're putting
out that's right yeah I mean you talked
about it on Friday so if you guys are
watching on Friday you know
so all right we have uh LS Joey says
watch Bill Mars comedy before his talk
shows his commentary was absolutely on
point makes his fall into ignorance even
more
stunning sad
reality but there you go that's just the
way it is dude how does he not know who
CLA Schwab is that is so crazy cuz he
doesn't read
still what the heck
Ian if you had $30 million in cash would
you really care anymore yes Bill Mah is
what 60 something years old how old is
the guy yeah something like that
probably he's probably just like I'm
tired man and then HBO's like Bill look
we're going to pay you another you know
10 million this here he's like whatever
and then he probably barely pays
attention he's just a goofball just a
goofball checked out he's checked out
and I don't blame him I mean he's he's
smoking cigars and drinking whiskey he's
single he's got no kids yeah most
comedians existence yeah what does he do
he's just like super wealthy and not
curious about anything and has no
children what he do curious he
interviews really high-powered
politicians even he interviewed RFK he's
curious though like he could have a
Booker who's like you should talk to
this guy he's like what do they do who's
MK Ultra he is curious I'll give him
that if you listen to him so I should
again I'm being kind of hard on he
definitely likes to dive in on ideas all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.net thanks to viewers like you
so when you become a member this is what
you're supporting and you'll also get
access to the uncensored members only
show coming up in a couple minutes so
once again smash that like button and
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
we got a bunch of I put up a skate clip
today so um as we're gearing up to
launch the uh uh the boonies which is
our new skate show we are investing I
think probably close to probably more
than a yeah I think it's fair to say
over a million dollars in our uh
semi-private East Coast skate facility
we've got several pro skateboarders
coming out we're going to be inviting
other professional athletes in the
action sports area probably one of the
biggest investments into action sports
content uh right now so follow me on
Instagram at timcast if you want to see
some of those clips and uh kingsy do you
want to shout anything out yeah please
follow me I'm Kingsley Wilson on all of
the platforms and then also follow my
organization Center for renewing America
we put out a lot of great work on what's
going on on Capitol Hill it's been so
fun having you here uh I'm Hannah Clair
brimo I'm a writer for scnr also known
as scanner news I'm really grateful for
our team and everyone who works on that
uh tons of Journalism you guys should
check it out uh you can follow timcast
news on Twitter and Instagram still to
see scanners work if you want to follow
me personally I'm at I'm on Instagram at
han. B and I'm on Twitter at HC brimo I
think you should probably follow trash
House Records if you want some updates
on the music and uh yeah guys thank you
guys so much yeah subscribe to me on
YouTube at Ian Crossland everywhere else
at Ian Crossland I'll be doing some cool
interviews this week and more weeks
going forward so keep in touch I'll see
you there tomorrow uh pleasure to have
you again Kingsley appreciate your time
um and I just had a good time had a good
show hope you guys enjoyed it see you
guys next time we're going to pull up
that exploding house for the members
only show so uh come check it out yeah
it looks like the police we're trying to
break in or something but uh we'll pull
that one up we'll see you all over at
timcast.net